today was uh
somewhat depressing you know i covered
this on my earlier show at 4 pm so some
of you may have heard but we got i want
to get into it with the crew here and
then talk about a bunch of other issues
a guy in north dakota
crushed a teenager because he was a
republican
now he said he was part of a republican
extremist group which who knows what
that means but after just hearing only a
couple weeks ago joe biden say that maga
republicans were an extremist threat to
our country it's no surprise that the
what is the left called stochastic
terrorism that biden espoused resulted
in an actual casualty a murder this guy
confessed not only did he kill the kid
he then called 911 himself and said he
did it admitting to doing it because the
kid was a republican extremist
apparently and what really what really
bugs me about these stories is that you
get people like you know bill burr he's
a funny guy he's a good actor i can
respect that saying everything's fine
people aren't really mad at each other
and it's just like dude
you're just not paying attention and
while i can respect not wanting to freak
people out there's an issue with us
being like hey man like this kind of
stuff is is happening more and more and
it's kind of freaky just keep it in mind
and and i don't want people to
constantly be panicked or down or
anything like that there's a problem
with people acting like it's just
literally not happening at all so we can
keep calm and carry on but we got to
acknowledge that people are losing their
minds in this country because the other
story we have is that fbi whistleblowers
are coming out saying that we got a
couple things we got a letter from
republicans
that that the fbi is taking people off
child predator cases and putting them on
white supremacist cases and then we've
got whistleblowers saying that they're
trying to ramp up the january six
charges or claims to make everything
sound worse and make it seem like a
crisis
yeah something crazy is happening in
this country so we're gonna talk all
about that plus the migrants that ron
desantis sent to martha's vineyard are
suing him
and the sheriff is trying to investigate
him for for crimes apparently and then
here's the funny thing apparently
desantis bluffed
there was a plane chartered to go from
texas to delaware to biden's house and
then nothing happened
very interesting so we'll talk all about
that before we get started my friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
to support our work directly we've been
hearing a lot from many of you watching
the show that you're not getting
notifications anymore there's a variety
of reasons this could happen not
entirely sure why but you can help out
if it is censorship by being the
notifications those of you who tune in
at 8 pm every day no matter what
you can share the url to this video
across social media to make sure other
people who aren't getting notified will
get manually notified and it would
really really help us out and also
become a member to watch our after hours
uncensored show monday through thursday
as well as our other shows like cast
castle good funny jokes if you want to
watch them and tell us from the inverted
world is good fun so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends joining us
today to talk about this and more is
vanessa
hello
santos
great to be here who are you i am the
ceo and president of red renegade public
relations and i do media representation
and pr work for conservatives and
center-right
orgs and people and this is why it's
fascinating you're effectively a bridge
between
conservative organizations people and
anti-establishment at ibook essentially
to corporate mainstream press and you
get to hear what they have to say yes
and um there is a bit of a code for a
publicist to sort of
not really share the reactions of things
but it is ugly out there and um you know
to be on the receiving end of this anger
when i'm just you know
pitching out
what what what conservatives what
center-right people are trying to do in
the media it's it's it's ugly
nice well we're we're getting tim's uh
fixing a camera at the moment
well it's nice to get introduced hi my
name is lukadeski of we are change.org
and uh you know since uh man bazonkas
are in and trendy i decided and of
course also approved by school boards in
canada i decided to pay tribute to the
man bazonka king himself mr bill gates
in this wonderful um
very voluptuous portrayal of him on my
t-shirt uh which you could get on the
best political shirts
provided to you by fake meat uh and
i also failed today uh i i got the
trainer came out paid for him and ian
didn't work out
all right there was some luke told me
that i committed to today which i did
not check the record
camera yesterday review
you you were like you're working out
with me i'm like
but i was talking about friday
but actually i met brandon he's the
trainer he's awesome i love the guy so
we're gonna be there next tuesday and
watch and okay maybe set up a schedule
with them that was uh we're gonna be
kickboxing it's fired off 20 push-ups
immediately after we got into it about
working out so i'm ready to roll awesome
well i'm really looking forward to this
evening we love vanessa we have a lot to
talk about let me zoom out a little bit
that's way too close on my face yeah
let's get into it this is kind of
disturbing news well i do i do have one
more uh we have another story that we'll
get into
so i've been covering the individual who
has the big oversized novelty breasts in
canada
and youtube flagged both of my videos as
adult content oh really for simply
showing photos of the teacher now i
emailed google and said this is
transphobic and they responded with we
will correct this immediately wow well
what they really said was there are many
people that are dealing with the same
problem and i'm working to get it fixed
and so it just is very funny that i
basically gave them a binary choice
is it really adult content inappropriate
for children or does google agree with
it and think it's transphobic and google
is like we will re-monetize this content
for you that opens the floodgates to a
lot of literal adult content and fetish
stuff we'll get into that stuff but
let's jump to this first story from
timcats.com
north dakota man admits to running over
and killing teenager for allegedly being
part of a republican extremist group
this is crazy for a variety of reasons
look it's only it's been a couple weeks
since joe biden said that maga
republicans were an extremist threat to
this country and we said that's that's
dangerous rhetoric that's the kind of
tribalist rhetoric that results in
violence the left likes to claim oh
donald trump's engaging in stochastic
terrorism and what he's saying is going
to result in violence against
journalists no less now what stories do
we get a democrat is allegedly uh ism is
arrested for allegedly murdering a
journalist
and then it is what i can only assume is
some unhinged liberal who runs he runs
down he hunted this kid down the kid
apparently called his mom saying he
needed help because the guy was chasing
him down
and then he chased him into an alley and
crushed him with an suv because he was a
republican extremist this kid alleged
extremist alleged well right he accused
him of being a republican extremist part
of a republican extremist group that's
was his justification this guy
it's a cult these people have paranoid
delusions joe biden is inflaming them
and yet they keep pointing the finger at
the the dude in the magazine sitting in
his lounge chair drinking a beer
watching the game problem with pointing
a finger at any group is like and i'm
gonna use the the age-old nazi metaphor
but like people are like i heard this
meme going around punch a nazi in like
2018 i'm like no okay this is a bad road
to go down you might think that the
nazis were the bad guys and maybe they
were but the nazis thought the jews were
the bad guys and they thought the jews
were an extremist radical organization
that they wanted to remove from the
country you see how that went when you
start persecuting groups of people
it's very very bad
it's tribalism it's our side is the good
side and these people are evil the only
problem is
there there there is truth and there is
fiction and so what do we have here we
have a show like this granted we engage
in tribalist rhetoric often as well but
i think there's a difference for one we
say things like hey those guys who are
violent on january 6 should be arrested
and prosecuted
what do we hear from kamala harris and
joe biden their staff and kamala and
personally bail these people out
we see violent rides swimming across the
country what do we get justification
that what do we get chris cuomo saying
who said protests need to be peaceful
you get calls from the corporate press
the mainstream media justifying calling
it a peaceful protest and you get us
begging them to stop even saying that
the the trump people on january 6 should
be charged as well when you've got a
right that's saying we want the violence
to end and a left encouraging it the
left then blaming the right but the left
is actually got the ones who are
literally running people down aaron
danielson shot and killed yeah there is
a serious problem and there is a tribal
problem
and this is not the first time that this
happened there's a number of incidences
in washington and in portland
all throughout the united states in
colorado i remember seeing footage of
you know someone getting shot i remember
that there's other footage of a man
at a part of a blm antifa rally that was
hiding
behind a wall that came out and shot
someone because of their political
opinions uh there's a number of people
that of course were shot were killed
were executed for their political
beliefs and seeing this in the united
states is absolutely horrible because
the united states is supposed to
represent free speech it's supposed to
represent a country where we could talk
through our differences and be able to
speak freely and be able to accept each
other for our political differences but
now we're meeting speech with guns and
people shooting each other which is
absolutely crazy religious differences
too sometimes people will say that
america is a christian nation but it's
not it's a nation where you're allowed
to be christian
well it's built on the foundation of
christianity though yeah i mean
christians built the foundation but it
was the idea that anyone could practice
any religion here with the christians as
they were building it yeah no no i'm
sorry i i was just going to say you know
everybody keeps talking about how badly
we all need to be communicating with
each other but
when you see things like this and all
the instances that you just listed off i
mean
this is why people keep their
voting preferences private this is why
people don't want to engage people
they're actually scared
i mentioned this earl on my earlier
segment about bill burr
because he did uh he was on trigonometry
and a bunch of there were a bunch of
articles written about it and people
were quote tweeting him and stuff like
that where he said
you know this hate online isn't real go
outside
smell some fresh air people aren't
fighting they're not angry like they are
online
and it's just he's wrong
and as i explained it is
people in liberal cities aren't fighting
with each other for the most part
sometimes they do they're right there's
riots people in conservative areas
aren't fighting with each other
sometimes but usually not
but if you look where the two sides meet
there's clash chick-fil-a being a good
example a fast food chicken restaurant
but the the people who run it were
making donations to christian
organizations so what happens the left
shows up and they are belligerent i
don't want to say violent because they
were mostly just protesting these
buildings but you actually see when ann
coulter goes to berkeley or goes to new
jersey to speak and they all show up and
there's riots i think it was when milo
was going to speak at berkeley they
actually started setting fires and
smashing windows spray painting threats
to liberals even
so that kind of stuff
you know that's
i don't know you made a good metaphor
that's what's happening before the show
about the bill birth thing because like
you're saying we're we as you know
journalists and watching the news are
like in a watchtower and we see little
bits of chaos around pockets of it so
for bill to walk outside and not see it
in his immediate surroundings and claim
that it doesn't exist is a problem it's
it's inaccurate it's an assumption that
bill's making because it does exist and
you're right too i i don't want to
inflame it and make people start
fighting because but i do want to
acknowledge that these things it's not
like it's not happening you know we
gotta we gotta find out why it's
happening and maybe we can provide
comfort and and reasons to
you know not happen you know get past
basically what i was saying was uh
this show is us standing on a watchtower
and we can see off in the distance we
can see people fighting in pockets and
we're like we don't know if that
fighting will come here but we know it
is happening all throughout the land we
can see fighting emerge and when we when
we when we shout down to the people who
are at the ground level and we're like
hey there's a crazy fighting happening
bill burke what are you talking about
everybody down he's having a good time
and we're up here like
yeah but the fighting's getting crazier
and like there's more people down there
like no you're crazy it's totally fine
and then it's sooner or later it may or
may it might come here it might not i
don't know you don't need to live in a
state of constant fear and anguish over
it but to deny it is worrisome i think
that it i think it has come here and i
feel like the guy driving this suv who
killed this poor kid oh my gosh my heart
breaks over this was probably blue and
on he's probably on twitter getting all
fired up and he's taking it out to the
real world i think this is also the guy
who shot that guy in portland and the
probably what happened in denver too
that luke was referring to earlier i
think it's coming to the real world is
there any evidence if it was personal
between these two guys he knew the guy's
kid's mom
apparently apparently the mom knew who
he was i don't know if they knew each
other
but uh apparently what happened was
there's a street dance party the kid was
leaving
they had some political words between
each other probably something like fjb
or f donald trump or something who knows
and then this adult 41 year old man
confronted an 18 year old the kids got
spiky hair and braces
yo be an adult be a man and be like get
out of here kid i got time for this walk
away no no no
the dude gets in his car and starts
hunting the kid down the kid calls his
mom
and says he needs help because the guy's
chasing after him
the dude then dr follows him to an alley
runs him over crushes him killing him
and by the time the mom gets there she
finds her son dead horrible it makes me
sick you know what i think
and i understand the problem of
you know recognizing the problem of
tribalism but being part of the problem
of tribalism there's nothing you can do
about it i view it as that that old um
riddle you come across a fork in the
road and there are two men you know one
on the left and one on the right one
always tells the truth and one always
lies
and that's what i feel like we're
dealing with
the democrats overwhelmingly as an
organization and the neocon republicans
uniparty trash people like lindsey
graham are just liars just outright
liars
the culture war right tends to be honest
and truthful the culture war left tends
to be deceitful and manipulative it
doesn't mean every person on the left is
deceitful manipulative and doesn't mean
every person the right is honest but
there's tendency there's the rule and
the exception so when you see joe biden
come out
and say that my republican extremists
are a threat to our country
and not a peep
from the left about stochastic terrorism
but celebration
then donald trump comes out and goes you
have fake news and they go he's going to
get a journalist killed
so criticizing the media is terrorism
but joe biden calling half the country
extremists who are going to destroy this
country is to be celebrated it's to be
accountability
i have no problem saying yeah donald
trump's rhetoric i did i wasn't a big
fan of and and i constantly heard from
people that he was too brash and too
aggressive and things like that and i
think rhonda sanchez has more tech
that's why i'm kind of leaning towards
him i have no problem criticizing what i
think is bad and then i have no problem
criticizing joe biden but one side will
all outright always just keep defending
themselves keep defending themselves no
matter how bad they are no matter what
they do no matter who they kill no
matter how much damage they cause it
seems to them they've done nothing wrong
why they have one goal and its power
yeah i think the people in the know on
the left or in in control of the media
whatever this is is there they're over
seeing like an old guard the liberal
economic order which is about to manipu
change into a world economic order um
and so they're willing to lie to protect
it and to make sure they guide it the
way they want to guide it the people
that are voting for that i don't think
are
in understand what's happening they're
just kind of following what they're
comfortable with and donald trump made
them very uncomfortable so
i was i was kind of thinking about this
earlier i was like why is it that they
seem to be
totally unmoored from reality and i
think at the left is in fact unmore at
the right
you can call me biased i definitely am i
think that we actually have a grasp of
objective truth and i think that's why
you can make an argument from the right
and be like well i think this is
entirely the case here's why i have news
articles for you they'll just dismiss
you they don't care what you show them
you can show them cnn and they don't
give a crap what you have to say because
they're convinced tim talks about it
being a cult
i don't know if cult is the right word
it feels like they've been brainwashed
like they've given a lot of the
responsibility for what they do over to
someone else which i guess you could
call a cult but
yeah i wanna i wanna uh mention
something
i read an article today from the bulwark
you guys know the bullwork sorry we're
all bit yeah
they're great uh the bullwork is awful
they're like what are they supposed to
be like anti-trump conservative or
something never
but they they actually wrote something
particularly interesting they wrote how
the civil war could start
and they said in november of 2022
and uh
yeah oh boy and then i read it and i was
like they're not wrong
not it's it's speculative but here's
here's the here's the the the gist of
their opening thesis opening argument
during the midterm elections
there's going to be left-wing and
right-wing people outside of polling
stations in swing districts and in many
areas of critical importance
and
what could happen
is that the right fearing fraud
is
watching every door watching every
entrance
of course in some of these jurisdictions
many of these people are armed or maybe
not but either way
in some of these areas you've got
democrats who believe that republicans
are paranoid q and extremists who are
going to disrupt the legitimate
elections because of their paranoid
conspiracy fervor
all that matters is two opposing
factions are at a polling place when
something looks amiss
and then you get one of either side
saying something is wrong here
an argument erupts because neither side
will see
what the other side sees it'll never
happen they'll say they just pulled the
ballot out i saw them what are they
doing who that's the second ballot the
the liberal side is gonna be like this
is it they're trying to steal the
election by lying about fraud again
and then what happens when it comes to
fighting doesn't matter what kind of
fight what happens when a polling place
gets shut down because of left and right
conflict now they went on to to describe
a man drawing a gun a fight breaking out
and someone getting shot then someone
filming the video and the video going
viral showing a poll worker getting shot
and killed at a polling location that's
an interesting point that i think it's
possible
not necessarily probable what worries me
is that fighting is in my opinion
probable with with 2020 this is the
first big election and more than half of
republicans believe there was fraud so
what's going to happen i think is that
you're going to see a lot of areas
conservatives trump supporters
republicans
out camping in front of these these
polling places 24 7.
you will potentially get a fight or an
obstruction to the point where they shut
a polling place down they shut down a
polling place in one area and all of a
sudden you've got procedural or
statutory
conflict now there's going to be court
cases was it legitimate because people
couldn't go to vote people going back i
wasn't able to vote because the trump
supporters shut it down trump's report
is going to be like the left showed up
in anti-fun we were fighting if that
kind of conflict reaches polling
locations then i don't know if it's it's
it's like a shot heard around the world
fort sumter style started the civil war
but the bulwark's argument is that could
be a catalyst for people saying
the election
doesn't work like it doesn't happen
something interrupts it and we can't
come out cleanly with knowing what
happened because this stuff could become
i don't know ubiquitous yeah that's what
shay's rebellion was was they shut down
a bunch of court proceedings they were
the courts were trying to take their
their property so the farmers went and
they surrounded the courthouses and were
like no and then the the court the judge
is really well i'm not getting involved
because there's like a thousand dudes
that are gonna kill me if i do then they
made a bunch of arrests the government
did they arrested a bunch of the farmers
it was chaos and then eventually they
just pardoned everybody because you
can't move forward as a nation if you're
arresting half your citizenry there's
always going to be a left no matter
where you're always going to see people
to your right even if they're on the
left because they're right of you and
you may
there's always going to be someone
opposite of you that's the nature of
humanity i actually tweeted this out i
wonder what you guys think about this
if a republic hacked its own election to
prevent a psychotic mob from taking over
the government democratically
one i thought that some you could argue
that that might be righteous and i'm
interested what you guys think about no
i think let's say there's a group of
psychotic
murderers that want to cut people open
as their cult ritual and there's more
enough of them that they can
democratically mob rule the vote system
and win
don't we have a republic intentionally
to prevent that
well sort of i mean first if you're
talking about people violating human
rights in the constitution then they
would be in violation of our government
which is why the constitution is so
important if a group of weirdo cults who
are like if you vote for us we'll
sacrifice children on an altar at a
pyramid to moloch or whatever like
overtly saying it and trying to do it
then it wouldn't be
those attempting to stop it would
actually be on the side of the continent
so if it was more subtle like we're
going to give transgender hormones to
kids we want to make kids trans like a
weird cult you can make it whatever you
want i see you're saying and this is why
i think civil war is and if a republic
were like you know what
whatever that is there's a lot of them
but america must reign supreme we're
going to hack the election and make sure
like is that would that be ethical so
here's the issue no hacking the election
is not ethical and the issue of
the point of the republic is that
there's a lot of ideas that we don't
like and we think are violating our
rights and so long as this is done
procedurally and
there's there's a limit to uh
how should i say this if they're going
and saying vote for me and then we will
we will we will pass through legislation
the right to murder people we'd be like
no that's a violation of the
constitution i infected the death
penalty as well
and even though we're seeing important
things
what prevents the country from falling
apart prevents conflict war and things
getting worse is that we agree to
legislate things and debate them and
challenge them eventually however as you
mentioned is good point we get to an
issue where they're like castrating kids
and and bragging about i mean this this
stuff coming out from matt walsh is kind
of crazy the vanderbilt stuff yeah um
about the profit incentive and stuff
like that for doing this you get to a
point where it's like okay we've got a
very serious problem that's why we have
a convention of states we have many
legal mechanisms to deal with a
government you know that is not doing
its duties or is is overreaching and
things like that but i'll put it this
way
if they are outright violent
constitution then i don't think it's
hacking the election i think
they're the ones who are committing the
wrong what concerns me when it's not a
violation of the constitution it's just
a change in the culture that i
personally think that's why we have a
republic is to prevent a mob of
democratic psychos changing it and i
think what happened was they think that
maga was a mob of democratic psychos so
they think that they're justified and
that's in the fortification of the
election and that time magazine put it
sorry i was just to say i i feel i feel
like this this particular organization
has not gotten enough press but there is
there is an existence the committee for
safe and secure elections and it's law
enforcement and election officials
working together
and um
you know i think that all the listeners
i i hope the left and the right both
look into this organization because it's
helping
it's helping to i think kind of
guarantee that that this doesn't erupt i
know i know i know what you're gonna say
no stopping it from erupting is good but
here's here's the problem
if if joe biden
uh his brain is broken we assume it is
um i'm saying like if it is let's just
say diagnostically confirmed he's the
president and if you've got a problem
with that we have the was it the 25th
amendment i believe yet for removing him
and that's the process by which we do it
we don't allow
lunatics to be like our country is in
danger so therefore i will take it no no
no no
you think donald trump's a threat that's
too bad people want him to be the leader
you do not unilaterally decide that you
are smarter and that your your
intelligence allows you to supersede
how our system is intended to function
although in the military and this isn't
good probably not good but there's like
they would frag their commanding officer
if they thought the commanding officer
was going to get them all killed they'll
be like no someone would slip a grenade
into the tent in the middle of the night
and the commanding officer would be dead
in the morning and then the next guy in
charge would be like okay i'm taking
over we're not going to attack i don't
know about that dude what are you
talking about it's a pretty horrible
aspect of like vietnam a lot of like
fragging the commander they'd kill the
commander if they didn't agree with they
thought the guy was going to get them
all that's the problem with the draft
that people have to serve a commander
they don't people people who don't want
to be there are forced to be there and
will say screw you yeah
but now we have robots that will take
care of all the fighting but anyway i i
think it's also important to note here
that our political differences have been
weaponized especially when it comes to
big tech social media which is connected
to the intelligence agencies that has
been pushing people further and further
on the political spectrum and you look
at the echo chambers created you look at
the radicalization you look at the
concentration and promotion of
negativity i think a lot of this brings
the hallmark of a divide and conquer
agenda that is being done deliberately
where today we are here in the united
states where there's legitimate yougov
polls talking about how 40 of americans
think that a civil war is likely within
a decade they think that for a very
specific reason because when you go
online that's all you see the negativity
the hate the fighting all of that front
page always and that has a psychological
effect on people and we are conditioned
towards the blue-collar working-class
people of this country fighting against
each other and that's the trajectory
that we are on that hopefully we could
avoid but but there's too much fuel
being added to this fire in order to
avoid this pathway i want to pause you
right there because it's not true the
democratic party is overwhelmingly well
off and there was a poll i think it
might have been yougov as well that
found when you pull people above 100 000
a year they overwhelming want joe biden
to remain president and when you pull
people under 100 000 of which there's
more they overwhelmingly want him
impeached it is not blue collar versus
blue collar it is it is suburban liberal
elites who are angry that working-class
people elected donald trump to be the
human molotov cocktail yeah but but this
case in north dakota who was it it
wasn't an an elite person it was two
people going at it and one person killed
another person so so you know we're
talking about the average americans here
there are
elite people calling the shots here and
saying hey i want him in power and him
in power but at the end of the day who's
going to be doing the fighting neighbors
people who are next to each other people
who are related to each other people who
are friends and family members but
because of the political differences
that have been weaponized in this
country they're going to be at odds with
each other and of course fighting each
other which is absolutely tragic okay
and i can agree but now let's let's
let's dig a little deeper
is it bad that powerful elites will
weaponize the differences between people
to divide and conquer and maintain
control of course they've always done it
will you then decide to compromise with
those who are castrating children luke
no
so what's the solution
i think i think that's that's one
particular position that of course is
strongly uh divisive i think there's
also a lot of mental health disorders
that lead to a lot of people to be
radicalized in that particular position
i think there's a lot of unhealthy
people i think there's a lot of people
who are not thinking clearly i think the
solution
you know is a very vast one and i talk
about it a lot but specifically that's
one specific
hyperbolic extreme example there's other
examples that i think do divide uh that
that do bridge this gap things like
abstinence things like federal overreach
things like taxes things like people of
course just being taxes
yes and no because
at the end of the day who's happy paying
taxes i don't think anyone is i don't
think that
even even trump supporters that that
rapper lady that would that endorsed him
i forgot her name uh what was her name
um
she just made a recent political
statement
nicki minaj she even made a whole video
would be like where are my taxes going
where's my money cardi b cardi b was
like where's my money
where's my money
taxes
the military-industrial complex i i
think there's a big push back against a
lot of these things because at the end
of the day they don't serve the interest
of the american people the american
people know that they're being screwed
but every time they're being screwed
they're being told hey the other person
did it to you but hey the other person
did it too and it's not just like that
it's not black and white well i don't
think that we should just gloss over the
trans stuff and i think that we need to
make these extrema's answer for what
their extremes are you know i think that
taxes are one thing and everybody can
kind of agree on on on how you know you
don't want to pay too much or whatever
but you know we're we're at a point
where
like
you know i'm sending my kids to school
i'm thinking about where i'm going to
live i'm thinking about where you know
what what communities i want to be in
and who i want my neighbors to be and
it's just gotten to a point where
i uh
i don't think people should be allowed
to just not talk about it anymore like
if you're going to be a part of this
party who's doing this to children who's
supporting these children then i want
you to answer for it i want to know
i want to know why you think this is
okay like this this can't just be
oh you know this is just a fringe thing
like this this isn't really happening it
is happening and you know the vanderbilt
story i mean i i we have to make people
answer for it yeah we should definitely
talk about the matt walsh stuff later on
but you know as it pertains to divisive
uh ness in rhetoric and things like that
there are people who
i think the media wants us divided for
sure
i think uh
i think for the most part you know fox
news has their problems
tucker is a bit abrasive but
he's okay
i you know maybe not necessarily the way
i i do things he's he's much more
comedic and he showed like a picture of
lori lightfoot as beetlejuice
that's not that's not the kind of thing
we do i know luke's a big fan he loves
sucker
i think he he's one of the few people
that actually criticized donald trump
and one of the few people that was
actually able to put his feet to the
fire and call him out on a lot of
important issues i think he's good i
think he is and i think for the most
part the media is overwhelmingly liberal
aside from the one you know channel and
then uh they're manipulating people
through just lying
emotions
culture yeah like i was watching video
game play footage last night pixelated
apollo what's up dude playing some
mountain mountain blade 2 banner lord
call me at some point gamers started
going let's go boys come on boys let's
go boys and it's all about the boys and
they talk about boys like their audience
are boys and i'm concerned that it's
like an insult like it's like i'm just
not comfortable with women so i'm
comfortable with guys let's have our
boys in the military there's boys but
what's happening
what's happening is young girls are
watching the video and they're like i
want to be part of this because if a
girl is ever like let's go girls it's me
and the girls tonight i get really
annoyed at that i'm like why are you
like excluding me from this conversation
so i think young girls are seeing this
boy's rhetoric and they want to be boys
i think the problem is that there's a
lot of women who like i mean lydia and i
were actually talking about this before
the show but i was a tomboy when i when
i was growing up i wanted to be a boy
sandlot was a huge movie i was not only
in love with benny the jet rodriguez i
wanted to be benny the jet rodriguez and
if if i had some you know
booby teacher
uh and i was being encouraged to to act
these you know silly childish immature
thoughts out i mean
you know i i might not be a mother today
and that's really sad and scary it's the
chemical castration of people under 18
that is very concerning it is it's
terrifying we'll get into that i want to
i want to luke mention something i think
is really important and just to to keep
the through line going this is a crazy
story coming out of the washington post
pentagon opens sweeping review of
clandestine psychological operations
complaints about the us military's
influence operations using facebook and
twitter have raised concerns in the
white house and federal agencies
how about that what luke yeah how about
that right i i saw the story story i did
a report on it earlier today and
facebook and twitter surprisingly also
took action on this and removed accounts
that were running what what is being
described here by even the pentagon u.s
psychological operations that were being
run on the american people these were
clandestine psyopses that were of course
pushing a narrative pushing an agenda
using your tax dollars to open up social
media accounts in order to brainwash the
american public this is an extremely
dangerous story let me read this the
researchers does not did not specify
when the takedowns occurred but those
familiar with the matter said they were
within the past two or three years some
were recent and involved posts from the
summer that advanced anti-russian
narratives citing the kremlin's
imperialist war in ukraine and warning
of the conflict's direct impact on
central asian countries significantly
they found that the pretend personas
employing tactics used by countries such
as russia and china did not gain much
traction and that overt accounts
actually attracted more followers
so what do you see when you go on reddit
it is laughable
i'm sorry there are people who fall for
this but here's the sorting algorithm of
the left and the right in the culture
war when you go on reddit and you see a
video of a ukrainian guy and he's like
smoking a cigar and he's laughing and
he's like this is what i think of russia
haha and they flip they all high five
each other like that's propaganda you
have cyber command you have
psychological operations you have them
producing this content
faking it so that they can put it out
there and convince you that we are
better we're stronger we're going to win
this war
now i don't i don't have a an issue with
it to a certain degree but it is
extremely annoying often when you know
these videos are outright propaganda and
then what happens now we're seeing
vladimir putin reigning these these uh
incendiary devices all over cities
threatening to mass mobilize the
entirety of russia and that there's fear
he could potentially open a second front
maybe finland we don't know but all the
propagandists in the military keep doing
is saying ukraine's winning russians
losing rush can't win and then russia
doesn't isn't even using a their their
pinky in this conflict they're to be
fair they're getting pushed back
ukrainian forces with nato's assistance
are advancing all that's true but what
they want you to do they want you to
believe that russia could never win for
moral reasons they want people to put
ukrainian flags we we drive down here in
virginia there's there's a little small
town you gotta drive through and you're
passing through and they have big we
stand with ukraine and i'm like you
couldn't point to where ukraine was on a
map
it is it is psychological operations to
convince the american people to support
mass spending of war yeah all of this as
of course western politicians like boris
johnson are on record telling zielinski
not to come to negotiations not to offer
peace not to try to stop the conflict
this was another bombshell story that i
think is definitely worth talking about
is the western governments telling
ukraine hey no peace deal no
negotiations here continue the war this
is perpetual war that i call that from
the very beginning cnn was telling you
is only going to last a few days i was
telling you hey it's probably going to
last a few years might even last 10
years might even last forever with the
way that of course the
military-industrial complex is shaping
itself in the way that they've been
funding themselves and the way that the
stocks have been of course increasing
but but again the these psyop pages here
are are worth noting because the
pentagon is going to be ordering an
audit on the dod for these psychological
operations that are played out on the
american people and this is what we know
about what don't we know about what else
is happening behind the scenes when it
comes to psyopses since of course
again information has been weaponized
and it has been weaponized against the
best interest of the american people one
thing is talking plasma where they fire
lasers into the sky and coordinate a
bunch of different lasers to get a ball
of plasma and then they move it around
and say it's a uap unidentified aerial
phenomenon and they're freaking people
out making them think that there might
be aliens well this is this is what they
did in vietnam short-lived they played
uh audio recordings of people wailing
saying
i should i'm trapped here forever run
run home to your kids don't be like me
and it freaked even the south korean i'm
sorry the south vietnamese out so i
think they're doing i want to answer
comments on videos too so when you check
your feed and you're like this is the
response okay that this is the thoughts
of the day that's psyops that's i think
i think reddit was taken over a long
time ago twitter i'm sure youtube they
can't control it people are coming from
outside and using the platform this is
why twitter they're trying to implement
algorithmic feeds because then they can
justify controlling people which is a
point you often make about knowing the
the code to prevent this kind of thing
because if you don't know what the
code's doing you don't know how facebook
twitter and reddit are manipulating you
to twist your thoughts to make you
compliant but i'll tell you one thing
there's a story i read recently i know
you guys probably heard about mass
graves in ukraine
did you guys hear this story no no
actually
i heard a lot of different stories about
mass graves in europe so you've got
you've got two factions in a war
obviously we as americans are expected
to support ukraine because nato and all
that stuff but there's two stories the
story from the west is that the russians
created mass graves the story from
russia and eastern sources is that
russia told ukraine to collect their
debt and ukraine refused so the russians
gave them proper burials
choose who you believe
i i don't i don't believe russia's
narratives it's the same bs their
military their psychological operations
are going to be are going to be coming
at us the exact same as the u.s will is
a battle for your mind it is fifth
generational war absolutely and the
first casualty of war is truth and i i
think you can't believe anyone because
everyone has an invested interest in
using information for their own personal
benefit but at the end of the day we
have seen a concerted effort to push for
a perpetual proxy war that there is no
end to that endangers all of europe that
is creating an energy crisis that is
creating a scarcity problem that is
creating a food famine problem for a lot
of the people in the world who are the
poorest people in the world and and this
is something that is absolutely
mind-boggling because even coming to the
table and saying hey there should be
negotiations there should be peace deals
we should be incentivizing the end of
this conflict in some shape
form or way where we could actually come
to the table and actually negotiate a
stop to this utter madness because
politicians sending people to die for
their political ambitions is one of the
stupidest idea in recorded human history
and it needs to end and it needs to stop
and it stops when the people stop
complying and i think this is an
important message that i think a lot of
people need to hear and sadly you don't
hear it on reddit you don't hear it on
social media you don't hear it on the
corporate media you don't hear it by
government officials you hear the
opposite of that and this is why this
conflict is going to continue but
they're losing i i think the information
war you mean that annie leibovitz got a
very beautiful photo shoot
yeah that's what's important tell me
about that
it's a joke
vogue did a whole spread on uh
on the first lady of
ukraine yeah yeah
in in the war-torn
country she's like sporting beautiful
pea coats it's it's pretty toned up i
don't know if it's true but i heard that
zolensky was wearing these nice these
like nikes did you guys see that
like really nice shoes i mean he's a lot
dab nice shoes it's fine whatever he's
very but but i think i think we're
winning and i think back to uh the bush
years didn't the dixie chicks they like
criticized bush and then they got they
got cancelled or whatever yeah
everyone's like you gotta support the
troops
nowadays
it's creepy how the institutions and the
establishment are waving ukrainian flags
and just you know
just well i'll keep it family friend i
was gonna say something you know uncouth
but uh you know just just uh abiding by
the cult narrative in support of the war
but uh shows like this can exist where
we just say screw your war and screw you
and that that's that's something you
know that's powerful it's at least
you know a message out there but still
tragically so many people are losing
their lives in ukraine so many young
people are just having their entire
existences wiped out because politicians
have ambitions and that to me is just
such a crazy idea a politician saying
hey go kill your fellow neighbor right
now because i said so i think it's wild
that this has happened throughout
recorded human history and it needs it
needs to stop a lot of it is like
utilitarian they're saying okay if we
don't invade the middle east
afghanistan for that oil we're going to
lose 100 million americans are going to
die from starvation in the next 50 years
so are we willing to sacrifice 2 million
people to make sure that the 50 million
don't die and that's the strategy and
the planning of resource management i
mean war is resource management it's
land management and and resources um
it's not it's not just that it's them
saying if we don't go in the middle east
china will
that's also you take that into account
like if we don't invade someone will
which is
not just that simple the us involvement
in the middle east propped up iran iran
is this powerful has more of a sphere of
influence because of the war in iraq the
war in iraq created isis created radical
sectarian violence if you look at it
it's not as simple exactly they want the
chaos they want the murder they want the
destruction they don't want the war on
terror to end they want it to continue
and they made sure it continued by
radicalizing groups and also pushing
people out of the government in iraq
which literally created isis
who is that guy who was in congress who
was right about everything
um his name was dr ron paul
yes he's just right about everything
yeah i love there's a viral video of him
going around recently that it's actually
gone viral several times where he's just
calmly explaining what is happening and
what will happen based on the things
we're doing and like it all happened
yeah blowback i think was his term in
like 2007. he was very very vocal
yeah i have a t-shirt saying if i told
you so was a person with him smiling on
it
but he called it he called it especially
when it came to the fbi the
politicization of the fbi that
historically has been going on with them
abusing their power that they had in
washington dc he talked about the
patriot act he talked about the war on
terror he talked about the war on drugs
and all of those roosters are coming
home to roost because he was right dead
on the money on so many issues and he it
was like he had a magic eight ball he
predicted all of it and it all came true
and if you would have listened the world
would have been a better place well i
think what we're seeing
with the anti-establishment wave was
deeply influenced by him and the ron
paul revolution back in i think it's
like 2008 the tea party revolution which
was hijacked by glenn beck and other
kind of uh stronger neoconservative
right-wingers but that was ron paul or
what ron paul originally uh was one of
the
major figureheads behind the tea party
that was pro-freedom pro-free speech
anti-war pro-america
and then a lot of other right-wing
figures came over and kind of hijacked
it and it became just like a republican
thing and it became an establishment
thing but originally it was
anti-establishment anti-us federal
reserve anti-imperialism anti-uh you
know globalist but i'll say this you
know when i was growing up in the city
everyone's very liberal
we all saw the viral ron paul revolution
we saw the stickers everywhere and i
remember seeing it says like it says
like revolution and love is backwards or
whatever and like ron the revolution the
ron paul love revolution what a funny
it's so weird at ron i don't think he
came up with that some people just
started doing it right i think yeah it
was viral marketing because his ideas
you know spurred on so many people to
take independent actions there was
people that literally had uh you know
air balloons that that had
huge you know signs billboards that were
just put up without the campaign's
coordination and his message was able to
get out there because of grassroots
support he also was supported by u.s
military service members more than any
other candidate in that specific
election that he was a part of and he
galvanized a lot of people to take
independent action without any top down
control which was very impressive i just
i think i think uh
ron paul's influence had a huge impact
on our generation because i mean 2008
was it it was something to that and it
was for a few years even after that
people were talking about his ideas and
what he what he what he believed and
what he represented and the things that
he got right even today and then there's
a lot of people now who have become
they very much were seated with these
ideas of libertarian values
anti-establishment anti-imperialist now
there's many many more people who share
the views of ron paul not to mention his
kids actually in government and carrying
on quite a testament to his his
personality that his child is such an
amazing human being
is really incredible and boy do
does the cult hate it but it's because
of ron greatly not not completely that i
think we're synced to strong
anti-imperialist anti-war
anti-establishment pro-individual
liberties pro-freedom movement i think i
think that what he represented and stuck
to rippled out it's unfortunate that
bernie sanders ultimately caved to the
establishment in the end because he
could have he could have stood for
something on the left in a similar way i
guess i got to talk to you guys about it
and and he kissed the ring and he bowed
down and they screwed him over and they
slapped him around he said please give
me more and it was disgusting to see
exactly him him just
just just give up and and screw over all
of his followers he had grassroots
support too he had individuals saying
hey i don't i don't need to be paid by
anyone i don't need to be organized by
anyone i stand for his ideas that
represent the middle class the blue
collar working class of this people and
then at the end of the day he pooped on
all of them let's just be real with
ourselves i'm trying to put my mind in
the state of someone in the government
in in control of the war machine and why
they're doing it because i'm very
anti-war i'm very like yo get the troops
out of the middle east we shouldn't be
invading people
end of story killing is wrong you know
very kind of black and white and then i
start to think like well wait if there's
a military if there are resource
management issues and and the american
people really are running out of
resources or are projected to that
unless we invade and take them from
somewhere else
where does good and evil starts to lose
that's not true that's a notion that
that is absolutely made up that is
that's
absolutely
and has has no sense at all dude we're
not going to murder the savage we're not
taking the resources
no one took the resources in afghanistan
the chinese are taking the resources in
afghanistan after the united states gave
it to them on the silver platter are we
taking any resources from libya no we
just brought back slavery to that but
like there's there's no conquest of of
resources
none of that there's a british no it's
not as simple as you think it is i think
it might not be as simple but the
british took north america and took the
resources on the east coast of this
continent and then they murdered 90
percent of the native american
population calling them savages didn't
consider them human for the resources
and now we have one of the most
bountiful resource country on the earth
you're you're technically wrong it was
individuals doing it all right the crown
i mean i was reading i i i was reading
about the war for independence recently
and i was like i wonder what the king
what king george was kingdoms the third
i think said when he received the
declaration of independence he ignored
it he handed up some other guy and said
i don't know you deal with it they
didn't care the crown didn't care he
thought of the the colonies as a
nuisance what it was was individuals
trying to find a better life they were
leaving europe the colonization was
in some ways you had elements of
trade and the crown was like there's
riches to be had but what people don't
understand about colonization is that
it's best represented by what we're
seeing now with china regular people in
china
move to other countries they set they
they set they create lives there they
grow they expand they create businesses
they gain influence that's colonization
the colonists from europe came to the
americas to find a better life it was
crowded a lot of them weren't succeeding
in europe they said i'd be better off in
a new frontier and those individuals
created cities created colonies and had
conflict the natives and they favored
themselves over the natives who lived
there so it's not like the crown was
just like there's people there let's
have all of our people go and crush them
by order of the king yeah they just
wanted the resources of the tobacco and
individuals
companies individual people yeah but it
was resource greed i mean maybe not
greed maybe that's just the nature of
humanity is more resources more people
and if you don't get more resources then
you're going to starve exactly you take
two dogs and you put them in a cage and
you and they're both hungry and you
throw in one chicken what's going to
happen are they going to share so now
probably my my thoughts on conquest is
like sh is shaken i'm not so like no
more war never everyone be peaceful now
i just don't it seems too pie in the sky
it is i i i think um the problem i have
with the united states is they've never
justified at least in my lifetime any of
their wars they claim they have
justification but it's always some weird
bunk reason they keep lying to us about
so my attitude is you do not get my
consent in a government uh that is
granted that is supposed to have the
consent of the governed you don't have
my consent to lie to me to justify why i
should do work pay you taxes so you can
go blow up kids barack obama there's no
justification for that you want to prove
that a reasonable doubt that someone is
worthy of death you have to prove it and
they've not done that so if they were
like just saying i think it's the petro
dollar i think it's they want a unipolar
world because they don't want to deal
with competition they don't want a world
war it's the liberal international
international economy it's it's this
we're better off with the power
otherwise it would be worse and that
does not get grant you the right to
execute people in other countries or or
for these people in the middle east
these little kids come out of their
houses and they see drones flying
overhead and they never know when that
drone is going to blow them up it's a
psychotic way to force people to live
they they do not have my consent for
that yeah if they were honest they
wouldn't have everyone behind these
larger ideas and these larger conquests
and these larger acts of murder because
if they were honest they'd be like hey
we're just trying to get some money here
we're a hammer everything's starting to
look like a nail we need to make some
profit here and ian they're not going
for resources and bringing you back
resources they're not doing that they're
helping their friends in the
military-industrial complex there's no
bid contracts there's there's the
weaponization of of the us military that
of course is in private hands that only
take care of those private hands and
even screw over the soldiers that
volunteer themselves because they think
they're fighting for freedom and
democracy they're not and you know why
you know why one of the reasons so many
people wanted donald trump just one of
the reasons is that
whether or not you actually care about
those kids coming out of their little
houses and seeing another drone flying
overhead and wondering when they'll blow
up maybe you're thinking like i don't
know about those kids i don't care i'll
tell you this that drone in the 50
million dollars that equipped it could
have gone to your town to your schools
to your roads to your industry to your
jobs and instead it's being siphoned
away by a bunch of morons who will want
a nation built in afghanistan screw the
whole thing up and then hand it over to
china money hungry murderers let's just
be real with ourselves maybe they know
no bounds when it comes to destroying
and killing other people and and they'll
do it to the tune of hundreds of
thousands millions yeah they have done
it before lateral damage why because
they don't want them what resources did
you get from uh syria what resources did
you get from afghanistan what resources
did you get from libya tell me oil what
resources did you get from somalia we
didn't no i mean we didn't as far as i
learned in iraq for instance there were
lots of oil we get oil from saudi arabia
and we still finance their lethal uh
genocide of the people in yemen which is
a proxy war so we're that's where we're
getting oil from saudi arabia from iraq
like oil but if we ran out of oil here
people would start eating each other no
under donald trump we were near energy
independence and i know it was a
pandemic and demand was weighed down but
gas in some areas dropped below two
bucks but on average it dropped way down
and donald trump was moving us towards
energy independence we are able to do it
now joe biden's doing the opposite he's
shutting down pipelines he's saying no
to fracking environmental's got a
problem with it but i'll tell you what
what what the administration what the
democrats with the unit party's done
they
they don't like the pollution here they
outsource it to china
so what they do is they say we're going
to pass all these environmental
regulations so you can't do anything
dirty here how do you solve for that
then the only way to manufacture is to
manufacture in china where they don't
care about pollution so what does donald
trump do he says we got to get rid of
these regulations on the environment so
that companies can actually come back
and start manufacturing so that
americans can have jobs so that
americans can send their kids to good
schools if you want to do that these
days can see how bad schools are so that
we can be energy independent so that we
can use our own resources we have the
entirety of alaska they won't go near we
have a way to joke here with jack
bosobic and daniel turner occupy alaska
invade alaska it's it's territory that
we purchased from russia it's there it's
open and it is massive it is huge but
for some reason we're better off
shutting down our own energy production
outsourcing all of our jobs to other
countries and then getting involved in
wars in an attempt to justify why we
need the resources from them
what's happened now with ukraine and
europe is that we're seeing 45 inflation
in germany which is insane i think from
the last month for year over year
inflation now it's this major spike
they've been they've made themselves
dependent on russia and donald trump was
like you shouldn't do this
instead of solving the problems they
just passed the buck until it got too
hot and now everything's falling apart
in their incompetent hands was it like
you shouldn't be relying on russia you
should be reliant on us you should be
you should be paying your fair share and
figure out a way to i don't know how
about this don't shut down your nuclear
plants and he's like why are you doing
this start showing up your energy needs
you can't just sit here and let russia
dictate how much you pay that was the
problem russia through gazprom was able
to dictate massive prices so the u.s was
like instead of doing any that let's
just build pipelines down here through
syria one of russia's allies war emerges
from this the u.s in my opinion was very
happy to see the rise of isis because it
was destabilizing syria so instead of
actually dealing with the problem the
democrat administration was going oh
geez oh no these these terrorists are
just growing donald trump gets in ice is
crushed ukrainian conflict dissipating
biden gets back in all of a sudden
middle east destabilization syria is hot
once again the fall of afghanistan and
war in ukraine these people are
psychopathic morons and and they think
to go back to what you say is a good
question if you thought a crazy person
was was going to take over do you think
it's right to hack an election or
whatever these democrats think they're
justified in russiagate ukraine gate and
all of their nonsense because trump is
is crazy but the people supporting this
are just being treated like mushrooms
kept in the dark and fed crap by the
corporate press and by the politicians
who just want power and don't want to
actually roll up their sleeves and do
hard work the reality of the united
states is that if we brought the jobs
back lives would get so much better for
the working class but those powerful
elites they wouldn't be able to exploit
slave labor in foreign countries so
their net worth would go down they don't
like the idea of closing the gap of
wealth inequality in this country they
would rather own the industry send the
jobs to china pay a buck an hour make
tons of cash extracting and exporting
our jobs and wealth to a foreign country
meanwhile the american people suffer for
it and then we get the opioid crisis and
then we get foreign war and then they
expect you to send your kids over there
to die so they can keep that system
going donald trump comes in and for all
the things wrong with the man that is
worthy of criticism he says hey let's
not do that and people are like
okay a start you know we had dave smith
on the show i'm a big fan he's an
awesome guy and someone commented and it
was brilliant they said dave you know
dave says what trump did was still bad
and that shouldn't be the standard by
which we we vote and i agree but
someone commented this problem was
created over 100 years and it's going to
take a decent amount of time to solve we
can't just expect a 100 year problem to
be erased and i think donald trump was
bringing a lot of solutions to abraham
accords no new wars these things were
good bringing jobs back to america
bringing energy back to america making
this country about itself being like we
shouldn't be the world police we
shouldn't be blowing up kids sending our
kids we should say we're going to clean
our own room we're going to make our
country better and we're going to
encourage a rising tide so that
everybody's ships will will rise instead
what we have is
the clinton foundation the liberal
international economy or the liberal
world order as they call it saying we
should be in charge of everyone because
we are better men i disagree i was
thinking about this i i will no longer
call it depopulation agenda because i
think they're just trying to slow the
growth of the population growth and one
way to do that is to have less people
producing because they're going to be
producing a net amount less and one way
to have less people is war have them
kill themselves off yeah i really don't
like that
you have to wonder
about that guy right there
like i don't know if she i doubt bill's
like i can't wait for people to die i
don't think he's saying that stuff but
some people might be like well one
utilitarian way to make sure the
population grows slower is to have less
of them in the first place
the pandemics
that
let people die of sex illness like
illness like well they talked about you
know releasing bio weapons before and
you know we don't want starvation i
don't want to get down there lack of
water i i wanted to pull this story a
little bit to each other so you don't
look involved i wanted to paul the story
before i before i lost my mind and
ranted on foreign policy but uh this is
from just the news
fbi whistleblower alleges january 6
cases manipulated to create illusion of
national crisis i want to pause real
quick by saying something
we've ragged on the fbi but that's
unfair it is there is a dangerous
element within the fbi their top brass
is particularly bad
and they've been weaponized
however i had some federal agents from
different uh uh different uh entities
speaking to me emailing me and we've
even had current contractors come on the
show and talk and the issue is the
culture war is everywhere even within
the fbi even within the dea or the doj
whatever element of the dhs
many of these people are scared to speak
up and that's unfortunate but some of
these people are speaking up now and
these fbi whistleblowers are doing
they're doing the lord's work coming out
and exposing the corruption within the
doj
so this right here shows us the fbi
whistleblower coming out and exposing
what's going on not the first one that's
like the third or fourth that there are
very good people that work in law
enforcement at the federal level that
want to be stewards of the constitution
that want to defend our rights and make
our country better there are many people
that got into that line of work for good
reasons and now they're starting to call
out the bad and that's what we need so
to all the good law enforcement officers
and fbi despite what our anarchist
friends who come on the show might think
i think you're doing the right thing
coming out and exposing this and i think
clearly there are people who got into
this for the right reasons and now for
the right reasons they're exposing the
hypocrisy and the crimes so here's the
story
the top the top republican on the house
judiciary committee said monday a
whistleblower has come forward detailing
how the fbi is manipulating cases
related to january 6 to create the
illusion that domestic violent extremism
is a widespread problem in the u.s yes
jim jordan said in a letter to the fbi
to fbi director chris wray that the
manipulative case file practice was
being conducted by the bureau's
washington field office which was
instructing local fbi offices to open up
cases on their books that were in fact
simply related to the capital breach
the fbi's categorization creates the
illusion that the threats from dve are
present in jurisdictions across the
nation when in reality they all stem
from the same related investigation
concerning the actions at the capitol on
january 6 which was what 800 people
and if those people were violent
prosecute them
the republican lawmakers said the
whistleblower's description is
consistent with disclosures we have
received from other whistleblowers that
high-ranking fbi officials including a
senior wfo official are pressing front
line agents to categorize cases as dve
matters to fit a political narrative not
only this but i don't know if you guys
saw the other story
they're pulling fbi agents off child
exploitation and moving them to
domestic extremism what that's insane
especially when you see what's happening
in this country with schools and with
the media but it makes sense the cult
want to come for your kids and the
elements of the cult that are in the fbi
are still helping them go after your
kids well it makes sense for another
reason and that's because the fbi has a
long record of protecting the people who
abuse children whether it's larry
nassler jeffrey epstein and probably
many more people that we don't even know
about there was victims coming forward
children coming forward went to the fbi
said hey even in the 90s there's people
coming forward say hey i was abused by
jeffrey epstein uh you guys need to stop
him he's hurting children he hurt me fbi
ignored it for over 30 years i got to
deal with him
yes though absolutely what's the larry
giver story uh that that one gymnast
michigan state yeah and he would you
want to go on how's the fbi involved
well the fbi knew exactly what he was
doing and essentially decided to aid and
embed his actions
um and ignore the victims that were
coming forward once again so there's a
record of this there it happens more
than once and uh you know seeing
a whistleblower is you know optimistic
but but still by and large there needs
to be an entire reckoning when it comes
to the centralized bureaucracy that is
in washington dc that of course is
abusing its power so this is this is you
know a good sign that we're getting some
information but but we're just getting
wasn't this guy fired i think that was
the latest update this whistleblower was
was fired really suspended um i think um
i i remember reading about that
yesterday i'm going to try to look up
the story see if you can see we can pull
that up because these these
whistleblowers are heroes man
calling out the weaponization and
corruption within the doj it's got to be
scary because you're watching them abuse
their power to crush their opponents and
then you have to willfully choose to
stand against them so i have tremendous
respect to these these agents because
like i said man
this was a few years ago
i actually i met a guy i came up with a
conference or something and he worked
for one of the national security
agencies he was a contractor because
they're mostly contractors and he was
explaining that he supported trump that
he believed in the constitution that he
i think you know i don't i don't want to
say his race just he was not white
and and he said it's scary because the
same thing that we describe outside of
the of the of these of netsec they have
inside as well and he's like we don't
what do we do you know they'll just fire
you if you speak out so you try and do
your best to do the right thing but
i think there's a lot of good people
that are in there because there's a lot
of good people all over this country and
just got to call it the corruption did
you find it i think jim jordan was
speaking about this to tucker carlson
last night and he was talking about this
specific case you're not in here do you
remember that i i didn't watch but
that's the that's the article that i
read yes so jim jordan fbi whistleblower
um and um
i think it was jim jordan correct me if
i'm wrong that that the whistleblower
was found and suspended currently
suspended because it's really hard to
fire federal employees yeah so i got to
be corrected i'm speaking off off the
cuff just off of what i remembered from
last night just reading it and passing i
mean it's just outright creepy that
they're trying to fabricate this stuff
and for what you know what worries me is
that we had a couple people super chat
us the other day that that their friends
are being deployed
to uh the the pacific in two weeks yeah
and and it's like how convenient for joe
biden if a war were to break out with
china right before a midterm election
where they desperately need to cling to
power
or the illusion of a war i mean right as
long as people think exactly some
skirmishes
some some conflict that resolves itself
in december i mean he's a hero in our
media and xi jinping's a hero in the
chinese media and then they both win
their elections
man i don't think this extremist stuff
is really
is is nearly what what has been provoked
for it to seem by this these certain
media organizations like it never was
extreme in the 90s and 2005 and like the
the after 9 11 there was radical muslim
extremist talk and it was all about the
muslims and like
this weird diver divisive whatever they
must have earned a lot of money for
people whatever they can do to generate
hatred and propaganda just because they
want milk yeah we found that jim you
want to go ahead yeah no i i've just
hunted down the article again but jordan
said the whistleblower was suspended
from his job monday and what the
congressman called a retaliatory firing
so that's illegal isn't it sure yeah
whistleblower protection is is something
that is a real thing and if you come
forward with information providing that
the government did something wrong
you're supposed to be protected not
suspended and fired and punished for
whistleblowing on something that
legitimately is a problem in the united
states and leading to radicalization and
leading towards a larger divide and
conquer agenda from what i see it when
reached for comment by tucker carlson's
show the fbi said the threat posed by
domestic violent extremists is
persistent evolving and deadly that's it
didn't exist before 9 11 that's what i'm
talking about this persistent threat is
weird
i don't know if it's because they want
to raise money for the military because
they're afraid that as the liberal
economic order evolves into a world
order they want to maintain martial law
in the united states so people don't
revolt when they realize it's going to
be 30 bucks for a can of coke or
whatever
uh
that maybe that's why they're drumming
up so
the war on terror is just turning
inwards you know we had the radical
islamists that were financed by the cia
for so many decades you can only do that
for so long now you need of course
domestic extremism of course to turn the
war on tower towards the american people
we have all the national security
surveillance state already set up we
have all the national emergency
procedures already set up and it's just
only a matter of time until again it's
going to be turned inwards it already
has in my opinion and there's going to
be some very negative bad consequences
because of this like domestic foreign
thing is also the line's been blurred
right now like you get on a facebook
chat which is an american company with
someone and you're talking with someone
in canada all of a sudden now that the
fbi is involved or the cia's involved
because it's foreign and like that and
they're supposedly masking you as the
american but then what they do is they
ask canada hey who was that and canada's
like oh that was this guy it's like we
didn't do it
five eyes spy club baby that's the game
they play so i hate as much as i hate to
say this i am afraid this looks to me a
lot like another step in the civil war
because this is what i've been saying
they don't have enough of the supply of
white supremacy so obviously they're
fabricating it i was i was hearing i
forget who was talking about it earlier
today all my podcasts run together but
they're talking about how they're
fabricating cases of extremism in the us
so they can meet certain quotas within
the fbi which is mind-boggling but it's
exactly what i said was going to happen
looks like a civil war because as luke
said it is just the war on terror
brought home we could look at the women
with each other huh the whitmer thing
yeah exactly like 15 informants and like
four guys or something like that i think
it was like six guys in like 12 and four
and something like that yeah i don't
remember those exact numbers but there
was a lot more informants than you know
crazily crazy autistic people that went
along with the government setup that
essentially was was that case george
bush senior was talking about the new
world order in like the 80s late 80s and
even i think while he was president he
was talking about this so
do you i mean do you think that this is
like they're just anticipating a
revolution into a new global system and
they want to like have a strong domestic
military presence so that we can control
the populace when it happens trying to
understand sociopaths is not an easy
thing to do uh he was also a big cia guy
uh but but that's beyond the story here
again it's hard to quantify and
understand exactly what they're doing
why they're doing it i think even just
explaining what they're doing to the
average person out there and and
breaking the conditioning breaking the
matrix that everyone is in breaking the
trauma-based mind control is already an
uphill battle i don't want to go as far
as to speculate exactly why they're
doing it it the fact is they're doing it
and the first thing we need to do is be
aware of it yeah i think motives are
less important than what's actually
happening and knowing what what the
fallout of of the current events would
be is way more important than wondering
or knowing why they're why it's
happening i mean you do ultimately want
to know why people do psychologically
but realistically if someone's proposing
a plan all really matters is what's the
plan going to do i don't really care why
you're proposing it
i mean i just i just look at
you know all the families being torn
apart because of it and and the and what
the culture wore and and just these
divides and everything and that's
irreparable
and it's very sad
yeah we we uh i think it was larry elder
mentioning that he had good friends
that all of a sudden they just they
wouldn't they couldn't talk and that he
presented evidence to them and they're
like i don't want to read the evidence i
mean how do you like what do you do is
it it's irreparable
i agree
well it's it's hard too because
you know like women suburban women
suburban mothers
me um you know the like we're we're
we're a class of people who really don't
want to talk about this stuff we don't
want to acknowledge that there's people
like the canadian professor and in cl in
our children's classrooms and our
children's life we don't even want to
acknowledge it a teacher yeah
shops i mean it's it's something that we
just don't even want to discuss and it's
easier for us just to say well you know
this is it's not this is one crazy
isolated case like people want to live
in denial that is how they want to live
and then you know on on the flip side
when it's like these minor little social
justice issues they feel like they can
just toss out their opinions or you know
it'll it's like an easy one to show how
woke they are in the group of some moms
or something
but um
you know i i've reached a point and
partly was because of the last show uh
that i that i did with with you guys um
i'm just i'm just kind of done staying
silent about it and instead of trying to
open up this crazy debate with everybody
that i know my new goal is and i like i
think i'm going to try to coin the term
microactivism i'm just going to try to
just show
these people show these friends these
colleagues these neighbors of mine that
they're not
uh
that their way is not the only way of
thinking that not everybody's on the
same page so even if it's just like a i
don't know why you would do that even if
it's just something as minor as that i
think it's important for people to know
that they are not always going to be the
majority that they they need to know
that there's people who disagree with
their way of thinking that they just
can't go around scoring these social
justice points all the time they just
can't and in these little things that
that i that these microactivism
moves i think are very important to
start doing how much of the suburban
female vote though is just social
pressures i mean i think there's a ton
of it but i think that moms are more
likely
to
kind of i mean we saw it with yunkan
you can't mess with the mama bears these
are women who probably in the past well
i'm sure they hated trump i'm sure a lot
of women a lot of women did not want to
vote for trump uh it's the way that he
talked about women the comments
but you know
the youngest stuff
that to me proves that you can't really
mess with the suburban moms you can't do
the social justice stuff with their kids
you just can't do it you're not gonna
win
what was i i imagine what was the or i
should i wonder what you think the
catalyst was for the suburban moms to
wake up to the problem and then vote in
a republican
i think that uh part of it was the
horrendous rape case and the whole
school board was basically in on
silencing it i mean that's somebody's
daughter that's interesting and they
chose they chose to to cover that up and
to try to downplay it but this is
interesting it's it's you know donald
trump says things women don't like yeah
they don't like the way he behaves
and so they vote against him then you
get this story in in in virginia where a
female is assaulted and mothers quickly
respond i wonder if it's just female
centric right something they're seeing
affecting them specifically that's
causing the direct response
i mean
maybe i i i think the other big part of
it though is is is the the
these teachers and these these super
woke people in our children's lives now
too i think that there's a driving
divide to
just
i mean to divide our kids from us
and i think that's very scary are they
going to vote for desantis
i mean i i can understand not liking
trump right right what about desantis
well i think that how do you i mean i
don't know i for for me personally i
mean i i i could see a desantis vote
easily happening and i think it is
interesting to watch the left try to
demonize desantis as they are you you
can't you trump can't be the antichrist
and then desantis is the antichrist now
and he's actually worse than trump and
you can't just keep doing this forever
and ever and ever i got it though oh boy
i got it i got it correct me if i'm
wrong but if the santis gets super
ripped and then does that yoga handstand
thing on his desk that like trudeau did
i think he'll get all the links but but
but what if he also figures out
newsome's hairspray yeah
yes the hair gel i want to see them
debate they were talking about yes on
twitter they were chatting back and
forth or something about it it was about
their hair though yeah let's start there
let's start with their products and then
get personal and then let's talk about
politics it was a debate about hair so
so they were talking about products
right so gel versus spray they want to
get re-elected that's that's pretty fun
but i i i like newsome apparently wants
to like shoehorn his way in on biden if
biden does oh yeah and now biden's
actually doubting
he he was asked if he was going to run
he's like well it was a little too soon
it's like you were just saying all the
time you're going to do it but newsom is
like
he looks like a snake oil salesman he
doesn't know the sanderson military guy
yeah you know i mean he was jag but you
know i i genuinely do think um not to be
as as as crass as the joke about a hunky
desantis because trudeau women seem to
like but i do think that desantis is
substantially more appealing for a
variety of reasons he's younger
he is just let's just say it any any any
uh anyone can acknowledge he is more
attractive than donald trump himself
yeah of course
oh you're you think you think trump is
way more drinking i don't think desantis
is all that easy on the eyes i think
that if you put him in newsome
i mean i think knew some yes snake oil
salesman greasy ken doll sure sure but
isn't he like really tall yeah yeah yeah
sanders is like what five times that
could be uh that could be a kennedy
nixon tv tonight waiting to happen yeah
who gets sweatier yeah i think that's
why nixon lost that debate
we know that newsome doesn't get
sweatier because he wears fleece in 80
degrees
105 degree weather
so he's sweatproof well at least you
know look who if you put donald trump
next to rhonda sanders who are the
ladies going to pick
i mean trump
well after january 6
they're going to pick the santas i just
think that desantis you you eliminate a
lot of the baggage drama that women
didn't like yeah and so you bring out a
guy who's like i'm going to protect your
kids i'm going to do right by you he's
younger it's more relatable and i think
i think desantis is would get a lot more
suburban women i i think so too i think
that the way you know like the the
stormy daniels stuff the grab the pea
stuff like all the all those remarks
were nasty also i went back at one point
and started trying to find the old
episodes of the um of the apprentice and
they're all pretty much wiped now
they're all pretty much gone but at the
cup that when i did start this
little
venture or whatever the episode the
beginning episodes the way he treated
women was crazy and this was years ago
years ago but you know i mean i like
trump at first but yeah i mean i can see
how how regular women could be really
very much off put by the way he was i
think it's emotional and social for a
lot of for a lot of women i think women
are more susceptible to social pressures
than men yeah absolutely it's not i i
don't know how substantial it is but
it's just more we see it with instagram
we see it with tik tok
women are doing young girls are doing
these tic-tac things where they fake
terminal illnesses they're getting
tourette ticks from watching other
people yeah substantially more than
young men yeah and so when when when the
media keeps screaming over and over
again that trump is nasty and gross and
evil you end up with a lot of namely
millennial women who are just like yes
then you end up with a lot of male
feminists weaker men who are like
anything you say baby because i'm trying
to sleep with you and then you end up
with people voting and developing this
mass formation psychosis instead of just
being like i am a being unto myself with
my own thoughts and opinions and while i
do find trump to be sometimes gross his
policy positions actually are a lot
better than joe biden's so i'll vote for
that instead well that's why those men
on the street videos that that i think
you've had a couple guys on who who do
those videos they're so important
because it just shows that these people
have no idea about policy at all they're
totally just going with the grain yep
they have no idea and the emotions
people are emotionally manipulated i was
going to suggest we play mary kill bone
but uh that's not a family friendly
there's a game um
yeah but family friendly show over there
so
i don't think it's that appropriate but
on the members only show we'll do it
when the kids are in bed
that's great let's get the dancing
nancy pelosi the wood shop worker
and uh and uh hillary clinton all
on the show she's solving the formula
crisis single-handedly yeah absolutely
yeah when alex stein was on the show he
made an interesting um
point that the war in the middle east
has just kind of evolved into the war in
ukraine i hadn't thought of it that way
absolutely absolutely it was so blatant
another one started you know he also and
and it's funny because you it's like
like clockwork but he also ate the chip
and the one chip challenge you know he
actually approached dan crenshaw on the
street i didn't have a chance to talk to
him i was on the show with him but i
thought he was saying like you guys
served a bad war you're bad i don't know
if you but he was insulting him
personally i think he's coming so well
he's tight and stuff like that he said
you sacrificed you know i think he said
something like i could be wrong look at
you you know you lost your eye fighting
a war an unjust war or something yeah
and what the thing is if he had been
alive and an adult when in 2001 when
that towers came down pretty much
everybody believed but how old was he
how old is he he's not he's 36 yeah so
he's so he was like 14 he was young he
wasn't an adult but like when you when
you were an adult at that time you
everyone pretty much thought we got
attacked by terrorists so it was like
they weren't bad people for fighting in
that war it wasn't until later like in
2008 and seven that we started to
realize that we've been snowed so i hope
that dan crenshaw and alex stein have a
chance to talk again well i think the
issue is dan crenshaw
is
i don't he's he's what's the right word
for you know he started when crenshaw
started off people were very much
interested in in who he was and then he
started to become more and more
swampy you know
swampy and war hawkish and stuff like
that
yeah i don't know him personally i was
listening to rogan one time and i was
like who is he canceled on us twice yeah
i was listening to an interview on rogan
i was like who is that annoying guy and
then i looked over and it was it was dan
crenshaw i'm like oh my god why he was
like pandering to joe and like i mean i
listened the show got better as it went
on but i was kind of rubbed the wrong
way at first here's what i don't know
him i'd like to know him though here's
what i don't like alex stein what he
called crenshaw eye patch mccain he was
yeah he said really nasty
yeah i don't like that what i do like is
when alex was actually commenting aoc as
a sort of activist troll kind of thing i
like i i think that was a little crude
but he ultimately got a major story out
of that when he was confronted by
protesters and he said i love you all
and wish you all the best
that is amazing and i think that's
that's the brilliant kind of trolling of
laughing and smiling that he does well
like luke you never you approached a lot
of guys on the street in like dan
crenshaw's position larry silverstein um
i mean the list goes on rock child's big
numbers
i never saw tony blair bill clinton
hillary clinton i never saw you seen
island i never saw you insult there
there at home i never saw you comment on
their ugliness or their height or any of
that you were just like
here are the facts comment
and that was the way i think that's the
way you do it well you know i was a
little facetious sometimes when you know
kissinger was having his uh private
dinner being awarded the freedom award i
asked him how does it feel being a mass
murderer receiving an award for freedom
when you murdered and butchered so many
people around the world with your
horrible policies especially in cambodia
and afghanistan and chile and the middle
east keep going on and on and on but but
predominantly that was like the sixth
time i talked to him but the first
initial ones was always hey you talked
about how military men are dumb stupid
animals please explain this is according
to bob woodward who said this on record
that that you publicly made this
statement how do you respond and he said
you know
he called me a bunch of names he
actually resorted to making you know
trying to make fun of me and trying to
call me a horrible human being and me a
monster and me a war criminal which was
kind of hilarious and funny but uh you
know everyone has their different
approaches alex says his i had mine um
but they made it almost virtually
impossible to get to a lot of these
people but you know that's beyond the
point here and it's not easy you're in
the moment people get emotional there's
a lot of different energy going around
and it's very hard to kind of be concise
and control yourself and it's it's a
fine art being able to like talk to a
lot of these people i really like alex i
i will say this i like alex stein i i
think that he's he's very smart i think
he does what he does very well but i do
think he screws up because i think that
it's kind of like when tucker carlson is
calling lori lightfoot beetlejuice it's
like
it's so distracting
and you know when when they're winning
an argument then they do that stuff and
everyone's like ah it's like you have to
do this again it's like on one hand i
get it you know it makes it more fun to
watch it is it's rich entertaining it's
relatable i'm sure it really you know
gets the clicks and everything up but at
the same time it's like you're just
taking away from the actual
like you're winning without this you
don't need to do this it's like when he
did the big booty latina thing it was
like why are you doing that like
it was just it was gross and weird the
challenge is
afterwards aoc came out and claimed that
january 6 may have been an inside job
had alex not done what he did we
wouldn't have had her coming out and
calling for an active investigation and
i was like
that's a really good outcome yeah an aoc
don't justify the means man i mean aoc
also you know insults a lot of people
she also said we have to make
politicians uncomfortable yeah and she
called on for a lot of these policies
which you know she's getting affected on
so again there's a debate to be had here
what's the right approach i don't know
well it's not calling rosie o'donnell a
fat pig i mean if you want to lose the
will of the american people that's what
donald trump did and i don't want to see
alex go down that path
yeah yeah so that that's why you know
going back to the desantis stuff and
yeah the women vote right i think how
you turn them off right there so do you
think it was the women vote in the last
election that cost donald trump the
election from your work in pr
uh
uh
do you no i think it was the pandemic
okay
yeah i think i think he would have won
without the pandemic i think he handed
the presidency over to vauchi and i
think that
yeah
he lost the country he absolutely did
and then he tried to get bill gates as
his science advisor and he took advice
from bill gates and he implemented the
policies that bill gates wanted
admittedly bill gates is talking about
this right now bragging about it so he
lost a lot of people especially with his
administration starting the 14 days to
slow the spread which is just a horrible
horrible approach i just don't i i have
to say though i don't like that he gets
blamed for the such poor handling of the
pandemic because i don't think anybody
knew what to do and and it was so
everybody's favorite word it must have
been probably the
topi's word was unprecedented
unprecedented it was and trump thought
well i'm taking the advice from you know
dr fauci i'm taking advice from from all
of these experts you know and all of
these you know science people and
everything and he he did listen to them
at first i don't think he got enough
credit for listening to them at first i
think that's also what costs him
everything um but the left will say that
he ignored scientists and didn't take
anyone's advice and it's just you know
whichever side you ask they can
spew what he did wrong and it was a mess
and it was unfair and then of course
january 6 happened and that's it i think
that's a nail in his coffin so you think
2024 trump's not going to be able to
pull it off because of those things or
what i don't think that he's going to be
able to pull it off because of january
6. i think that any chance that he would
have had to try to come back i think he
he's he squandered it desantis though do
you think he'll win i think that he
could win i don't i mean i don't know
who the democrats would want who would
run who could beat him yeah what do you
think gavin newsom i think trump is
beautiful do you think gavin newsom
could beat desantis yeah whitmore is
going to run
this is going to run whip more yeah
i i think i think that if you i i feel
like newsome though should be defeated
while michael shellenberger could i
think dismantle him
but you take one video of
san francisco i mean how how can a bit
but i guess we talk about media ignoring
important things i mean outside the
front door of every major you know news
network is a huge homeless crisis
because it's a liberal-run city and yeah
so i mean he has this rambling he has a
slick look and buddha judge also has the
cie connections that could also bring
him forward people vote with their
hearts if the media makes it about how
nice of a guy he is that's the winning
ticket unfortunately that's what he
loves democrats
he looks like a politician i mean i i
gotta pull this story we gotta do one
last segment have you guys seen this new
uh article from common sense barry
weiss's sub stack no crime is a
construct my morning with the park slope
uh panthers
if you ever wondered
what it would be like for urban liberals
to try and deal with a crime problem
come over to commonsense.news where
susie weiss wrote up
this article so i'll give you the gist
of because i want to read everything
it's hilarious and it's terrifying at
the same time so there's this guy
he's he calls himself he says he's left
of uh left of lenin i guess yes he's
walking his dog and a homeless guy
whacks his dog with a stick killing it
yeah injured the dog they brought to
hospital emergency surgeries couldn't
save it so he decides to start a group a
neighborhood watch called the park slope
panthers
why because there's two panther statues
at the front of the park that's it so
they have this meeting and then these uh
leftists show up and start saying we
won't abide by your rules you want to
call the cops you're bad
there's infighting it's chaotic
they all start to just generally agree
with the absurdities of the left about
no police and creating a utopian society
where everyone just gets along and they
acknowledge that the homeless guy waving
the stick around beating people and
chasing women is just you know he's
being oppressed by these systems and
rejected
and then it ends with them deciding to
you know
okay we'll come back and have another
meeting and then they spray paint
they vandalize his home by writing don't
be a cop to the guy
this is what happens when your town is
overrun by crime murders homeless people
and your dog is murdered and you're like
okay the cops aren't helping us can we
start a neighborhood watch
young leftists show up
yell at you everyone fights and then
they vandalize your house
they were like we don't like that you're
stealing black culture by calling it the
panthers and some old woman's like
there's panther statues right there
that's why we're saying that and then
some lady goes let's call it the tigers
and it's just like a bunch of extremely
naive people who have no idea how to
deal with why their city is following it
sounds
people were actually asking if this was
satirical or not it sounds fake it
sounds fake hilarious you're not in new
york are you
no no i'm here well i'm
okay but dc is still pretty bad too it's
bad i was
you know telling lydia this this earlier
too you know i was i've been going to dc
a little more for meetings and
everything now that my babies are a
little bit older and um i can't believe
the homeless encampments and and this is
you know right outside the front door
basically of the cnn building i mean
there's just tents tents everywhere
there's tents all over they're covering
every single park it's i mean i've never
seen anything like it it's completely
crazy and and it's really sad too
because these people
you know it gets dark and it's it's
like it's like drug city and no one's
doing anything about it and it's violent
and scary and
i don't want to walk around alone in in
dc and for a while there i felt okay
doing it do you guys see casey neistat
is back in new york city nope
and so he started making vlogs again
because it's been a while he moved it's
funny he moved out right before the
pandemic and the lockdown and stuff then
everything got really bad then he comes
back right when it's all wrapping up
and uh his videos are great he's just a
he's a happy go lucky guy he makes fun
videos
i love to watch him but i just wonder if
he's going to talk about that stuff
because this was really interesting in
his latest vlog he mentions that new
york was being beaten down there was
riding there was looting there were
lockdowns it was brutal and then i was
like whoa this is starting to get good
like casey's outright just like new york
was basically under siege he's like i
couldn't believe i wasn't here for that
and now he's like i'm back in new york
i'm genuinely wondering if he's gonna be
like crime is through the roof and
people are being murdered and some dude
got pushed into the subway tracks the
other day or if it's just gonna be like
new york is fun and beautiful and it's
the greatest thing ever
it's hard to hide yeah it's hard to hide
your personal experiences especially if
you're doing a personal vlog so it's
gonna it's going to be interesting to
see a lot of this stuff i i wasn't the
biggest fan of him especially with him
promoting
uh rushed experimental therapies without
doctor consultations i wasn't the
biggest fan of him working with cnn and
promoting hillary clinton and you know
just naively talking about politics when
he didn't know a lot about politics so
it's going to be interesting to see his
return to new york city i've been there
a couple weeks ago and it's a crap hole
i hate it there's a bunch of like nasty
garbage everywhere there's there's some
it smells everywhere it's it's a bunch
of rats everywhere it's not a fun city
it used to be a city where you felt the
energy of the city the city sometimes
you know propped you up made you feel
like you're on top of the world
sometimes it brought you down to reality
but but it was a roller coaster ride now
it's just continually
down and low vibrational bull crap uh
nasty seedy disgusting energy that i
just don't want to be a part of and i'm
absolutely unhappy it smells like sour
milk yeah absolutely yeah people don't
understand that no it does it literally
does because it's damp and horrible and
it's shaded by all the skyscrapers and
it's just crazy you can actually see in
some areas you'll be walking by like
times square and there's just a a streak
of sour milk in the gutter when you see
that like cloudy white gray liquid
flowing down the gutters on the side of
the road and then a little
little rat especially down on in no like
soho like right right on houston street
when you that's where the fish markets
are and they come out at the end of the
day after just gutting fish all day and
they spray it on the sidewalk with their
hoses into the water into the street
they're not supposed to but everyone
does it everyone knows man it's like the
stuff like dystopian futures are made of
when you watch what's going on there
where were you when you were there
i'm not telling you
because i was on the upper upper west
side for an event we did like four
months five months ago and it was
beautiful was it that long ago it must
have been it was around that time it was
like in the middle like july or june or
yeah it's like two months ago yeah uh
and it was phenomenal it was so nice but
it was the upper west side yeah or east
side it was like the nicest part of the
city they closed down that fancy boat in
central park yeah i saw that yeah i just
you know when i saw that casey was
saying he was going back to new york i
was kind of just like this kind of feels
like bs to me dude because what is it
like a hundred something thousand
businesses were destroyed in the
lockdowns there's you know going to new
york i mean yeah there's people there
obviously there's millions of people
live there but it's not the same and i
wonder if his real goal is just because
he mentioned in his video
that uh it was being beaten down he
wasn't here for it maybe he just wants
to create a positive image of the city
once again or something i don't know i
think i'm proposing an idea right here
and now i think that the way people view
big cities whether they think they're
great like these leftists run big cities
i think that if someone thinks they're
awesome you can tell that they're
brainwashed because they're not awesome
and i feel like everyone can see that
who's looking at it objectively if you
don't agree that they're kind of
starting to fall apart or actively
falling apart at the end stage of like
near-death experience nonsense then
you're blind well that's that's a thing
when i so you know casey comes back to
new york and he's like making videos
again everyone's like he's gonna make
vlogs and he's talking about how great
it is in new york and he's showing
people like pogoing and other things
like that and i'm just like no you know
this video he's putting out really does
make it seem like new york's awesome and
then i remembered being there a few
months ago and i remember exactly why i
moved away from it first it was
constant pro violence
gunshots ring out in the middle of the
night in certain areas where i lived
because i was in i was in brooklyn
then we had uh two cops get murdered
literally on the street that i lived on
i i guess i'm just unlucky in that
regard but then there was another story
about cops who walked into uh the
stairwell of some project housing
building and then got scared in the
middle then it was dark out and fired a
bullet which ricocheted and shot a
random guy in the chest
things like this happen in new york city
because it's it's it's crowded there's
crime people are getting mugged there
was that was it she was 19 year old girl
up at columbia who got brutally stabbed
to death
and so on there someone planted bombs on
25th street a bomb went off someone
planted bombs on the jersey side and i'm
just like
you know what you know what you know
what i found
i was talking to this couple that were
from south africa and they told me that
it's not that bad they were like
everybody talks about how bad the crime
is we've only been carjacked i think
five times in south africa yeah and
that's what they told me only about five
times and i might draw the floor i'm
like five i was there i remember that we
were in uh what country korea yeah you
were in korea
and i was like that's kind of bad and
they were like
to them
it's like my friends have been carjacked
ten times me only five therefore crime's
not that bad as people as bad as people
say and it's like i'm from chicago i've
never been carjacked so people in new
york city right now it is bad there was
a
i mean let me let me show you this right
here from from barry weiss's from susie
weiss's article this is i wonder if
she's related to barry she says in the
last couple of months in park slope the
baby bjorn wearing capital of bourgeois
bohemian new york a thief absconded with
200 000 worth of jewelry and a smash and
grab three boys sold a bunch of iphones
off subway riders a ticked off customer
attacked the owner of a bike store six
thousand dollars was stolen from an auto
shop and a beloved bet was catnapped
from a bodega on seventh avenue this is
just park slope
and then the story of the main guy and
then in the on august third moose a dog
was uh uh and his owner jessica were out
on a walk when a homeless man gave chase
and hit them both with a large stick and
threw a container of urine on moose
while muttering about immigrants amazing
the dog died a few days later this is
just park slope it's one small area of
brooklyn to come out and try and act
like cities are doing well i get you
want to have a positive image that i can
respect but
i just come on man yeah reality is it's
bad it's a wonder of the world new york
city will be looked at as like one of
the great wonders of earth in the future
aspects of it you know the statue of
liberty the world trade center the
empire state building in central park um
and it's it's incredible to take it in
and see it and to be there and to come
up from the subway for the first time
and look up to 80 stories skyscrapers
all around you like there's a vacuum
that sucks your soul but
living there i mean you got to use
reason and logic and decide if you want
to be packed like a sardine into a city
with a bunch of other people where it
smells yeah like sour milk and other
chemicals
flowing down it's concerning how just
like empathy just dies
like you just stop caring for your
fellow man or something and it's just
like
you're just out for yourself in new york
and you don't it doesn't matter who you
step on what you're running over what
it's just it's
yeah that happened to me ugly that
happened to me i was coming back from
work after an hour and a half commute
for like the 30th day in a row and there
was a woman in front of me with a bunch
of bags on the stairs going down taking
up like three there's width for three
people to go up and down the steps but
she was taking up the entire width so i
put my hand on her shoulder and pushed
her aside not hard but i realized after
i did that i just pushed a woman what's
happening because if after her there's
going to be another person in front of
you and then another one checking their
phone and they don't see you and it's
like
i it's it's utilitarian you can't you
can't function when people are in your
way well it's like those videos uh in
japan when you have like subway
pushers like it's like it's like you
stop being hum it's like you just
stopped being yeah and now you guys
understand bill gates
and before we go
can i just interject real fast vanessa
and i were talking about this and i
suspect that what's happening in cities
is because everyone's crammed in on top
of each other i think this shortens
their lifespan of like their livability
because everyone's squeezed together
people just become objects that you have
to run over into they get in your way
they walk slow they drive slow they
fumble around at the cash register it's
irritating when you have too many
interactions with other people i don't
think people are designed to live in
cities you're not supposed to live in a
shoe box that smells like sour milk i
understand yeah you're not we're gonna
go to super chat so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends be the
notifications you want to see from
youtube that's right because youtube's
not notifying people the show goes live
so if you want to tell youtube don't you
play dirty games with us you guys can
really help us out by just being a
notification sharing the show and making
sure people don't miss it it really does
help and uh become a member at
timcast.com uh we're gonna have a
members only show uncensored we're gonna
play mfk i guess
and i have a announcement so a lot of
people were wondering why we didn't have
comments and it was because we were
trying to find a way to integrate
comments through social media and
all i can really say is in the end we've
just circled all the way back and we're
like okay this isn't working so i think
i don't know if we've already rolled
them back out but we're going to have
comments back on all the posts so that
people can effectively use the site as a
forum as they were
and members only comments will be for
members only so when you're watching
members on the content you're only
talking with other members on all all
other posts there will be public
shareable comments that you can see so
uh that should be a lot of fun for a lot
of people and i look forward to those
conversations let's read the super chat
asheboro says
all gains in the dow since biden took
office have been erased
yo that is bad
that's brutal
those gains were probably because they
printed all that money and they were
like stop probably the illusion of gains
yeah without investing in infrastructure
so um
what is it i i don't know have you guys
heard this a bunch of big retailers just
canceled their holiday orders
i saw just like 50 of them went out of
business like gap went out of business
there's a huge list of them yeah dude
i should pull that up i was reading that
like big box stores were canceling their
orders right before the holiday which is
unprecedented that's never happened
right and then
you get people chatting about guam and
taiwan and i'm kind of like the fedex
ceo i think was ceo or the ceo came out
c-o-o and he said a world a global
recession is coming
he's never seen this before a major drop
in stock tanks
i think the next few months are going to
get particularly spicy i mean we knew
the fall harvest was going to be bad but
let's see what happens now yeah if we
have 50 large companies declaring
bankruptcy they're going to get bought
up by like blackrock big chartline uh
giant investment firms
barney boyle this is crazy is this super
chat wow he says my cat's breath smells
like cat food
why cow what is happening that's a very
nice simpsons reference by the way
that's ralphie right
yeah caligula love says no notification
again of course gotta be the
notification that's right youtube wants
to censor us and take away notifications
well they'll get away with it unless you
meddling kids share the show
so that you can be the the notification
yes
principal gerson says it's a government
fabricated cult to overthrow freedom of
citizens
that's what they do that's what they do
ian bridges says tim i did it i moved an
hour's drive from the city to a small
farming town of 800. so quiet so safe so
clean so much less expensive
get chickens
yeah we're ian wants to get a i'm sorry
you know luke
you're not wrong i don't want to get a
yeah absolutely yes hold on but for the
wrong reason yes we're very much you
know luke human progression there's a
lot of reasons why luke luke was like
cows are great because they give you
milk and ian goes can i stick my finger
yeah
yeah yes
take care of yourself
uh congratulations though man um
yeah we're really excited about the new
the new uh property over at freedom
stand we have a a preliminary
fradamastani flag
and it's beautiful it's a shield crest
with a chicken head
i think it's fantastic yeah so i can't
wait for that to be done well we're
going to have a big i want to get like a
huge flagpole in like those 40-foot
flags and just fly it that's probably a
bad idea because then you'll see it from
very very far away
yeah i'm surprised i know where he lives
i'm surprised you didn't have your
viewers submit designs oh yeah that'd be
fun like a contest yeah pretty awesome
well you know jessica who is our artist
came up with a bunch of really amazing
designs she's just too good she's too
good
raymond g stanley jr says tim sometimes
it's hard to be optimistic biden will
only cause more death from his rhetoric
him and his elites care not for the
damage they cause no they just want
power all true
okay
all right ash bro says if it's okay to
punch your political opponent i'll buy
all the boxing glove necessary to see
congress beat the crap out of each other
unfortunately
for you ash peru and fortunately for
everybody else it's not okay and it's
actually a big problem that the left
seems to advocate for it and let people
get away with it meanwhile we're the
ones over here telling people to stop
fighting and then
stories like this happen
it's brutal man solas ginger says
remember that ralph northam add from
2017 with the minority children running
from the guy in the maga truck hunting
them down was that that's your aged
dwell i don't think it was northampton i
think it was more recent than that i
don't know someone look it up yeah i'm
pretty sure it was way more recent than
that yeah
maybe there's more than one
slain hope says i abandoned the left
when the lies got too much to bear the
right is rotten but at least they mean
what they say the left lies to get what
they want well elements of the right are
rotten the same as elements of the left
are rotten but on the right you have
libertarians post liberals disaffected
liberals politically homeless people and
the right is like okay you know we we
agree to work with you guys on the left
you have people who are like i will do
as i am told the media is always right
yeah i'm not okay with that
yeah it was northern
2019
all right
i'm not going to pronounce this how do
you say is uh
can tim say my last name today i smiled
yesterday the o what's it called an o
with two dots over it is similar to the
english sound
i in bird so um
those dots yeah but but there's a word
for the oh with the umlaut over it right
just say zoidberg zoidberg that's what i
would say
so uh
bird or you in the word fur so er so uh
right i imagine
you know what i'm going to get it i'm
going to say ola strawberry burke
strawberry
because this is america that's right and
in america we speak american strawberry
i can't pronounce your name i remember
when i went to
um uh sweden and i kept saying malmo
because i'm like i said oh and they were
like yeah but it's got the things on it
so it's mama and i was like oh yeah
i was like i don't speak swedish
the incubus says this is stage eight of
the ten stages of genocide
dude that chart was crazy and it's scary
man we don't like that and you know i
don't know
oh what do we got here josh berg says
just had deja vu about lydia comment lol
what is deja vu it's just like basically
your brain misfires real quick yeah
you've got a feeling you've been there
before but but the cause of it is that
your brain
misfires
um perception with memory real quick so
it feels like a memory but you're
perceiving it in real time so people
think i remember this
no you're experiencing it right now
right i will say though i've had a ton
of weird experiences where i've dreamed
things that have happened
that's what that's what i thought deja
vu is from dreams
i don't know man i dream things that
happen too though like i i have very
specific dreams and i often remember all
like to the t like places or what do you
mean
i dream places
i
like you just have you in your dream
you're just like seeing a place and
nothing happens yeah i see a location
and later i go there it's really
interesting but like is something
happening at that location no just
driving through so like you have a dream
of just like looking at a place yeah oh
that's weird i've never experienced that
it's really weird my dreams are like
things happen yeah like really crazy
stuff the weirdest thing is i had a
dream a few days ago and for i have no
idea why
it was like everyone from my
kindergarten class as adults and i was
in chicago and i was like when i woke up
i went i've never thought about those
i've thought about those people in 25
years
that was so weird and then i was just
like having a dream there a bunch of
them were there and i was like why
nothing throughout my day nothing in my
life made me think of that
i like i like the uh the multiverse
theory your dreams are just you
perceiving an alternate universe yeah
where there's no physics physics break
down in dreams there are like no laws of
physics not always
no you could establish them but they
don't have to be there well i mean you
could be peering into any universe you
know where sometimes the laws of physics
are different or maybe the reason you
can't punch in a dream is because you're
trying to control someone else in a
different universe
huh like in multiverse of madness you
know i have that dream all the time
where i'm trying to punch somebody and
like i can't go in that honey yeah you
try to read something and you can't read
it yeah yeah words and letters take
weird shapes so here's something that
will help all of you attempting to lucid
dream
if you can't read it and you can't punch
you're dreaming
so no but it's simple uh when it comes
to people who want to try to lucid dream
simply knowing that and being conscious
of it you'll be in your dream and you'll
think hey i just heard i'm that if that
happens i'm dreaming i'm dreaming i had
a dream last night i was riding a uh
like a motorcycle super fast and i was
like well i'm dreaming so i aimed at the
wall and i just hit it as hard as i
could and i just like bumped into it
like it was a video
game um i mean it bumped hard but it
didn't hurt yeah oh sorry i i just
remembered this dennis reynolds quote i
hate listening to people's dreams it's
like flipping through a stack of
photographs if i'm not in any of them
and nobody's had any sex i just don't
get it
that's a great question it's a great
thin man says tim check out the 1946
battle of athens tennessee the only
successful rebellion since the american
revolution i see a lot of parallels
between them and now i know all about
that story it's crazy but you guys came
back from world war ii saw that their
town was being overrun by politically
corrupt people and then were like nope
no and they just basically took it over
crazy story man crazy crazy veterans
baby
john galt says libby you are close the
right believes there is an objective
truth and seek to find it the left are
post-modernists who believe in relative
truth and rely on expert elites to
define it for them if you are not a
recognized authority to the left your
voice has no meaning yeah who's libby
i'm assuming he's talking to me since i
was kind of talking about that oh you
were yeah because i was talking about
like how we actually have an objective
objective truth that's why i think we
john did
did you watch the show previously with
libby on and assume that lydia was libby
yeah well it's that or linda so you know
whatever if it starts with an l it might
be well it works thanks luke everybody
everybody knows that linda's actually
your twin yeah and they switch back and
forth
it's nice that's right
yeah how else could the job get done
augusto mimoshe says thank you ian
america was founded on enlightenment
values which was basically a greco-roman
revivalist movement that dragged
christianity kicking and screaming into
the age of reason yeah they were
protestant they were protesting the
church the church had gone too far in
their opinion
not a banned account says biden have the
courage to arrest maga republicans i'd
say he does i don't know if it's courage
more than arrogance
yeah i think it's going to get crazy in
the next month
i mean yo october is here
the october surprise cometh
one thing i've been doing
war i think
i think biden might tell us he's not
running yeah
i think he hinted at that sick for the
60 during the 60 minutes interview right
i think biden might uh step out onto the
white house lawn in front of all the
cameras and then ascend into a being of
pure light energy and then beam off in
outer space
we need money to fund a rescue mission
i've stopped i'm starting to not think
about my work here is done man
i think if he had said i am going to run
that then now he's liable for all these
tax things about raising money so he
doesn't want to announce it i mean
that's kind of what he said right yeah
yeah that's exactly what he said and i
suspect that we're not going to make it
through october without them going after
desantis too that's my two cents we'll
see what happens dot dot q says hassan
went on flagrant with andrew schultz but
is too afraid or busy to come onto tim
cast man's just afraid of tim ian and
luke going ham isn't andrew schultz in
la though i don't know is he no i
thought so if he is i thought he was
located in new york city oh i think he
relocated to brooklyn yeah oh you want
to look that up so hassan flew out to
new york to go on andrew schultz but he
didn't want to come out here dude i love
andrew schultz he said he was too busy
and i respect that i mean because he
does his own show but if he's going to
fly to new york i want i mean first i'll
say this was he going to new york
because he had business and was able to
knock two birds out with one stone yeah
that's fine coming out to the middle of
nowhere in the dc area i understand why
people who have their own shows don't
come out like we want jimmy dore to come
out i respect jimmy and he's like i'm
busy man it's really tough and i'm like
i totally get you dude but uh we might
get jimmy jimmy's jimmy's great it'll be
really fun to have him on the show
hmm i'm i'm not sure where they're based
out of right now he was born in new york
city yeah it'd be cool to get anger on
he's a busy guy as well yeah yeah he's
super he's super brilliant dude yeah
i've talked to him in the past you know
hilarious too yeah we got to get him we
got to get him on that'd be amazing
jt fire says hey tim i want to recommend
a guest for either pop culture crisis or
irl shed m brooks is a pop culture
commentator who breaks down historical
accuracy of
meta combat and also the writing quality
of many movies in show do you mean media
combat is that typo i don't know i don't
know i've made a combat with something
yeah um pop culture crisis i started
having guests soon chad and brooks yeah
shut down they're taking off pop culture
crisis great show i'm gonna be on friday
they get they're getting a lot of subs
i'll be there tomorrow we we don't wanna
just you know some people are like why
don't you shout out pop culture crisis
more and i'm like because it's a
different audience we don't want a bunch
of political people to watch you know to
to go over there and potentially
subscribe to a channel they're not
interested in right we want the channel
to build an audience of people who are
interested in that kind of subject yeah
yeah so we we do promote them a little
bit you know but they're gonna they
gotta do their thing right
all right neglectful sausage says so
because they were voted in i have to pay
taxes to the groomer brigade so they can
mutilate children with autism who are
targeted due to not fitting in and can't
protect themselves wow there is a
challenge there in which
we either vote or
it's like you vote for the change you
debate for the change or you fight for
the change and we try to do everything
in our power to avoid fighting and
that's a very difficult line i can i can
i can say but
you know
passing legislation to get this stuff
made illegal is the best path forward
and winning the elections i was gonna
say winning the elections and running
for school board and and trying to
protect your kids in that way is i think
the best way and i wanted to give a
shout out because i work a little bit
with laura zork at freedomworks and she
is running this amazing group called
best and they are helping
parents and and concerned citizens run
in and win for school board positions so
that's exciting i hope you guys check
that out that's best in freedom works
king demi says tim i believe in your
efforts to be truthful in your
journalism yet i have not seen you talk
about the q anon guy who reportedly
killed his wife and daughter what are
your thoughts on this matter oh my so
there's a reason why i've seen the story
i've read it and ultimately just was
like wow that's crazy a crazy person who
believes crazy things and then kills his
own family i don't believe is of
national consequence now i understand
that the q stuff is crazy and he may
have been driven crazy by it but i think
after reading the story the real issue
is the guy was crazy to begin with
i don't believe the catalyst for him
killing his family was that he believed
a military you know
person was leaking government secrets
because it would make no sense why he
would kill his own family thus we have a
story of a crazy man who harmed his own
family when it comes to this guy running
over a teenager who was a republican
that is a man seeking out and killing a
teenager
with rhetoric similar to what joe biden
just said a few weeks ago that is of
more national consequence a man
murdering a a stranger a teenager
and using rhetoric similar to what the
president did
as for this guy who believed the queue
on stuff for what reason would he have
to kill his own family other than he was
just insane
he claimed like they were corrupted or
something you know their their genetics
or some other weird nonsense that just
doesn't make sense politically in any
capacity it's a crazy story um
but i just don't know if it if it's of
political consequence to a great degree
of course many of the uh blue anon
people want to call it the story and
point to it because they believe every
conservative is a q a follower the
reality is the q and followers actually
aren't that numerous they believe they
are
they're not i mean there's a lot of them
don't get me wrong but
the majority of the republican party are
not believing in weird conspiracies or
anything like that
so i just i just see it as a crazy guy
who writes something crazy and then they
try and use it as some justification
yeah
and maybe i'm wrong no you're right i
think a lot of times someone will if
there's a violent thing and one of the
guys was a registered democrat one of
the registered republican had nothing to
do with that it was a personal beef and
but then you get media spin where
they're like republican murders democrat
you're like what in the it has nothing
to do with that dude these are two crazy
people going at it
well the democrat just murdered that
journalist
where was that allegedly innocent proven
guilty
uh he was in vegas i think right yeah
like a registered democrat was he like
democratic party he's a politician he's
a yeah no but that one matters because
they said trump's rhetoric would result
in republicans killing journalists and
then it was actually a democrat who was
angry that a journalist was writing
negative stories about him and then he
gets arrested for killing him so don't
blame the democratic party for that guy
going over over the line no but you can
blame the democratic party for lying and
claiming trump was going to make his
followers go extreme and then it's
actually a member of their party
definitely accused of it blame moments
of rhetoric if someone spews it that
pointed out but don't blame the whole
group because some idiot waffle sense i
says tim you guys should really consider
incorporating money guns on your show so
you can better emulate the show pop
culture crisis on youtube you might just
get to be as successful as them one day
so um here's cool stuff let me let me
let me give you guys some secret
information
tim guest irl has no such money guns we
just read super chats but uh it started
with chicken city i i woke one day
and an epiphany
we should live stream chickens and make
it so that if you super chat food drops
down for those chickens and
once you super chat at least 100
a chicken party happens
and it was a tremendous success in the
first month of chicken city i think we
made like 30 grand it was insane we're
getting thousands of dollars a month i
was tweeting about a slice it's way down
now it's like but still i think it's a
couple hundred bucks a couple hundred
bucks a day and super chats for the
chickens to feed them and stuff and we
have way more chickens and then we said
for the next shows we do we should
gamify we should so this way people they
can get their super chats in and they
can also participate
pop culture crisis then incorporated
money guns when you super chat dollar
bills fly in the air after a hundred
dollars a crisis party happens and you
hear horns go off sirens and then money
starts spraying like crazy
for the new show we're doing with shane
cashman i don't know what we're calling
it yet but it is a live show discussing
weird wild paranormal mysteries unsolved
mysteries and it will be the more live
public component to the entails to tales
from the inverted world the long-form
show this
we are going to have it be that whenever
you super chat there's an element of a
storm uh wind blows thunder lightning
the room is going to be always dark and
haunting looking and then after 100 a
thunderstorm starts and so you'll hear a
low rumble and lightning in the
background as they discuss the creepy
the ghost stories the mysteries and
there will be candle lights flickering
and lightning going off and stuff that's
awesome and that will be you know
basically the people watching the show
have an ability to interact without
disrupting the show we've talked about
could we do something like that on irl a
way for super chats to have an impact
but i just don't think it would work
because you know as often as we do say
funny things this is just like a
conversational show
it's
serious sometimes political it's not the
same as these other shows yeah the flow
of the conversation is the key i think
on this show and i don't want to disrupt
that
i just don't know like look with pop
culture crisis having crisis parties
like it kind of fits the theme of a fun
entertaining show the mysteries and
ghost stories having a thunderstorm is
perfect like what would this be like we
get swatted yeah
fbi raids yeah an fbi guy comes down the
ceiling like you have a little smashes
everything
ruins the show points at the camera and
smiles actually okay i'll tell you what
here's what we'll do
we will create this the swap the swat uh
party for super tits and the meter will
be like 10 grand because then we have
the repair the ceiling the next day and
the flash bang drops down and it
explodes right in front of us
yeah
but here here's the truth the the the
meters and everything really do people
really love engaging with it so the the
the super chats for these other shows
are way higher relative to this show if
we did incorporate some kind of like
thing like that we probably have way
more super chats so i don't know maybe
there's something reasonable that
wouldn't be disruptive that we could do
it's on last friday we had dr drew
pinsky on and i was getting comments
that like man this is the first time i
wish you guys didn't do super chats
because the conversation was so good
yeah i wish there was an after show
because we could have gotten into some
really deep she is fascinating well
we're uh we're talking about him having
him come back really come back really
really soon and um hopefully with adam
corolla hopefully and then we definitely
going to do an after after show
because that will be wild adam's
fantastic and so is dr drew
cb says i have a customer that's
shipping out to guam october 31st he's
deployed for four years they're planning
for war in the pacific that's right
okay wait hold on i gotta read this john
marshall says and and
luke get ready for this one
just a reminder that because of ron paul
we got the clintons in office he split
the republican vote between himself and
bush senior not saying he isn't awesome
but he did give us slick willie really i
don't think that's the thing no that was
ross pro yeah
yeah yeah
ross perot ran as an independent and
split the
for the most part they're right so they
say i was too young to really know about
but that's that was not ron paul yeah
that was not ron paul
no ron paul ran the primary and what
does 2008 would you rather have a cia
bush in there i mean they're all bad you
got you know cia a drug running amina
arkansas clinton and then you got cia
drug running bush in there
it doesn't make that much of a
difference i loved ross perot at the
time i wanted him to be president
couldn't convince my dad to vote for him
though
my family was uh very much in favor of
him but then they all went very strong
democrat for the next several years i
guess because things got the economy
expanded was like 30 percent in like 95
i think so this is glad it was a clinton
that repealed glass-steagall is that
what it was let corporations invest as
much money as they want to political
things i don't remember but clinton did
something about like making the economy
look good by giving corporations a lot
more power all right neglectful sausage
says tim is right listen to him female
in group preference male out group
preference for women nothing in society
is so
damnable is that what he's saying unless
it happens to women which is why
equality matters one million homeless
men no problem 200k women omg crisis see
paul lam no i mean that that's that's
true uh and it's for obvious reasons if
you if you pay attention to like
evolutionary biology and psychology men
protect women women are more valuable
from from a biological standpoint than
men are because women have babies and
men don't i mean yeah nope pretty simple
yep
100 100 guys and 100 ladies and 99 guys
die that one guy can have 99 babies in
nine months i mean he'd be working
really hard but you know it's possible
i know a lot of men that would be up for
the task yeah
yeah but all 99 women die and you've got
one baby in nine months you're in
serious trouble yes yeah it's the end
man
so that's why we take it much more
seriously
all right steve smith says tim remember
when seth rogen told casey neistat that
he was cool with getting his car broken
into about a boot a boot 15 times right
after casey neistat had a bunch of
camera equipment stolen from his car
yes i remember that
ugg it's like that cartoon from that
that guy when he was like my bike was
stolen but the guy who stole it's
probably happier with it than i am
without it so the happiness in the world
went up and it's like gosh the dude who
stole it doesn't care at all about the
bike he probably just checked it for 20
bucks ugh so what are you talking about
he's trying to sue himself
that fat cat says hey tim the big
chested woman went to my school three
months ago if you want more pictures of
her i can give them to you for free i
would not want more pictures of her no
thank you ian do you want more pictures
oh my gosh you're getting me hot
no
no
no do not tweet that to me at ian
crossland
i don't want to see those at ian
i want to see those
all right jonathan harris says speaking
of gaming tim cast g4 tv irl went
actually really soon we're planning a
gaming show where we will have people
play video games and that will be a
whole lot of fun and then we'll show off
our video game so
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com because
we're going to play mfk if you know what
that means mary f
kill my husband's gonna love this it's
gonna be a lot of fun
and um
be the notification you want to see from
youtube if they're not sending out
notifications and it is impacting us and
you have an issue with that you can help
out by sharing the show and being that
notification because uh the october
surprise is coming and i will tell you
this
across the board not just on uh
on youtube we're seeing funky things
with analytics and it's kind of funny
because now is the time for everything
to go up the fall season is coming
viewership normally increases but we got
an election coming up so naturally
there's going to be weird things afoot
so you can help out by sharing if you do
want to support the work we do and you
can follow the show at tim castro you
can follow me at timcast vanessa do you
want to shout anything out
um
follow me on twitter at vanessa santos
xl
thank you for coming thank you guys so
much for having me this was awesome
awesome so i have a youtube channel
called youtube.com we are change i am
five subs away from 800 000 subscribers
there's a lot of people being
unsubscribed there's a lot of people you
know
being there not being there make sure
you are subscribed click the bell button
if you want and uh see you there
youtube.com forward slash we are change
yeah you follow me on the internet
anywhere at ian cross i also have a
youtube channel post a video last night
about artificial intelligence quite
interesting about how we should be
coding these things so that they don't
turn on us like decepticons uh when you
share the video with your friends you
can actually add a timestamp at the end
if there are points in the show you
really like and that's what they'll see
first when they click the link if you
want to hook them in to a moment that's
a good way to get them hey catch you
guys later
thank you guys very much for tuning in
this evening an announcement to make i
got rid of my cast whoo i have a funky
zipper scar i can barely turn my wrist
but i'm done with the cast i'm very
excited i'm on the healing path stoked
so i saw on socialblade that people have
been unfollowed from my twitter account
i'm sure no one would voluntarily
unfollow me on twitter so you guys
should all follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlitsmines.com sarah patrick's
as well as sourpatulids.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in about an hour or so thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you